we are meeting in a different room than
we normally do
um i am
asking all committee members present in
the room to be aware that this
microphone system is different
uh i request that you keep the red
button which is
speaker on all the time
keep that
unpressed
and when you speak press the blue button
which will have the microphone picking
up your sound that way we won't have
feedback we don't need to worry about
other things this is a different setup
because we are in the finance room which
is where
the big boys as i might say meet with
many many people so that's where we are
today
um before we get going i have a few
announcements
uh if you're using devices
try to turn the mute on i think the
microphones might take care of that in
this room
speak clearly please everybody in the
room because soft voices may be heard
but hard to understand
um
the the committee room will be muted at
lunch
we have a sign-in sheet for people who
want to register an opinion or speak it
was closed off at 8am this morning
if you sign in after that time i won't
have your name on a list but you will be
able to be
recognized during the zoom platform
if you want to register your opinion or
sign up that you have speak spoken if
you hadn't beforehand you can do so
until 11 59 tonight
in regards to this particular meeting as
chair of the election law committee i
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covet 19 payment
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order 20 2004 this public body is
authorized to meet electronically this
is a public hearing on bills referred to
the committee and scheduled in the house
calendar for today an executive session
may be held on any bill referred to the
committee please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of this committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with house rules
and rsa 91 a and if anyone has problems
accessing this meeting please call 271
3600 or email hcs at ledge
leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote before we start the rule call
attendance i ask that you all join me in
a pledge of allegiance and we will begin
our official business
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
before we begin the roll call i would
like to welcome representative murray to
our group
um
representative murray will be with us
today and wednesday
uh as a substitute for members who are
not able to attend representative murray
is not a stranger to the election law
committee room um having sat in it
before so welcome back and at this time
i'll ask the clerk to call the roll to
i am present i'm
calling in from home there was no one
else in the room with me at the present
time
representative barry
here
representative cody
representative
here
in my home
thank you
representative
here i'm in my home and my son is in
you need to unmute you're all set
representative hamer if you could just
um here we go i'm here
morning
representative
here
continue representative mcdonald prepare
representative mooney here
representative
president alone thank you
she's not here
representative kweily here
not i don't see her
here
represents rosie
representative murray
here in my home
i'm here
is that it yes
okay
all right thank you everybody um before
we get going with the first public
hearing
um i want to sort of go through what the
business this week for the committee is
going to be
we have public hearings this morning
on
uh
of course now i've lost the list
429 362 508 554
531 535 and 538
um i tried to have bills heard on the
same day that dealt with the same issue
last week we heard a lot about absentee
ballot bills this is a lot about
requirements um and
things related to actual voting
later today we will be having executive
session
um i'm calling these out because some of
these bills made it into the calendar
some did not um it's my understanding
that there might have been a little uh
glitch between the logging system that
staff uses in the calendar
but due to the notices we're going to be
able to proceed with our business but
and i'll announce this again at the end
of the meeting today we will be dealing
with 61 144 285 291
292 327 406
537 372
480 491
516 and
remaining bills and again we'll go
through this at the end of the session
that will be dealt with on wednesday
not necessarily to be dealt with in this
order are sb 43
sb2
538 554
uh
there 327 and 98 are also going to be
addressed i think today
in some form so we'll go through that
again at the end of the meeting but
because the calendar didn't have
everything specifically listed i wanted
to go through that
all right so for public hearings this
morning the first public hearing that we
have this morning
is hb 429
relative to hold on let me switch
something here sorry everybody
madam chairman mothers a brief break i
just want to point out that
representative lane has joined us by
phone
thank you representative lane welcome
and representative o'brien joins us in
remind committee members in the room
that your microphones
should have both the blue blue and the
red button in the up position
and when you speak press the blue
position and when you release your
finger from the blue the microphone will
hb 429 has been noticed for
9 30. it is relative to college or
university student
voting the prime sponsor on this bill
is representative baldesaro
he joins us here this morning
good morning representative baldessaro
okay here we go um thank you
thank you yes i am uh
in my office uh for the record
representative al baldus
rockingham county district five which is
londonderry
um the reason i i
supported this bill and brought it
forward was on behalf of some other
people
that had issues with college students
voting
i myself has a father of about five kids
that all got degrees
uh one with a master's i have no
problems with college kids
voting
the problem i have here is in the state
of new hampshire
is non-residents that are voting out of
our colleges um on election day
they're becoming red that means you're a
resident of new hampshire
and that you should be getting in
in-state tuition
i know one of my sons that were in maine
uh they called them many times there to
go and vote in maine they offer them
pizza deliver him to the polls and bring
him back but he already did absentee
ballot
um you know for new hampshire when he
was in maine
so my
mentality on this thing here is to make
sure that the students that want to
become residents of new hampshire
that they're protected
and they do not have to pay out of state
tuition there because the schools are
working hand in hand uh with the
students and with other groups here to
get them out to vote
um there is a gentleman who is going to
be testifying at bill durham bill hall
from durham
who called in he's about 80 years old
but he's
i'm not sure he
knows how to use the computer on this
here so hopefully they'll be able to
testify on what's going on at the
university of new hampshire with this
voting
the second part of this bill is also
since i sat on the committee on the
affidavits in the voter id years ago
the uh one of the mistakes we made was
putting in college ids
into the law
okay to be shown at the polls
and in my opinion college ideas should
not be used because they're non-resident
their families are taking tax breaks you
know while they're in college just like
i do with all five of my children
because they went to school out of state
and i know this is a 15 minute and i'm
going to cut it shot right there so you
can move on and do your business uh
madam chair thank you representative
baldus hour does anybody have any
i'm not seeing any
um thank you very much
uh i'm sorry representative mooney
representative baldassaro thank you so
much for your testimony quick question
do you know how many other states have a
similar law to the bill you're proposing
i don't think there's too many uh and
most states uh don't let your
non-residents vote in your state
uh so i don't have those numbers but i
know when i sat on election law you you
all probably know better than i do uh
that um
you know they're we're one of the very
few that allow students that are
thank you any further questions
representative o'brien
thank you madam chair uh
does this mean that people who come into
the state
and want in-state tuition
would would uh qualify for in-state
tuition right away they just simply say
that they're a new hampshire resident
right now i think the requirement is six
months of residency before or a year
perhaps i'm not exactly sure perhaps you
know or for the speaker down the line
we'll know but but is that what that
this means
what this means in my opinion is that
if you're a student you come into the
state and you go to college and you are
voting in our state you are saying that
you're a resident of new hampshire that
you plan on staying here our law already
says but then i think it's 60 days
you're required to get a driver's
license that's already in law
so all this is is tightening up our law
is telling these students in in the
colleges that if you're helping and you
know these students to go vote
then
you're helping them become residents and
we thank you for that then you should be
paying in-state tuition
thank you further questions for
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
um
we have a number of people signed up on
bills today
um testimony is going to be limited to
accommodate everybody on all bills
uh i will tell you on this bill we have
18 signed up in support
457 opposed
and 10 people signed up to testify
um testimony is going to be limited to
i've asked my vice chair to time it at a
minute and a half that will end up being
in about two minutes
most of these people said zero one or
two minutes and that's sort of
consistent throughout the morning so
that's where we're gonna go for
testimony so i'm gonna go through the
list of people who has signed up
is representative moffett online
is samantha paquette
online
up
is deborah nelson did i just pass over
miss nelson you are with us if you
unmute uh we'll be happy to hear for you
from you excuse me go ahead thank you
very much my name is deborah nelson as
you know and i'm a resident of the town
of hanover which has a significant
college population
and i
think it's unfortunate that the issue of
in-state tuition is cluttering up access
to the polls
and i think that
because we have students who pay taxes
they rent they
contribute enormously
to the businesses in the town they serve
as volunteers with
local school recreation programs they
serve on hotlines for suicide
concerns they are active and involved in
our community
they are not seeking any particular
break in tuition and as a former public
school teacher
who taught civics and american history
for 27 years i think it's critical that
we do all we can to ensure
everyone
everyone has access to voting and i
don't think it's at all inconsistent
that students who are living here for
four years have the ability should they
wish it to vote in this state
and i thank you for giving me this time
i'm mindful that you don't want people
to go on and on but again i'm a resident
of hanover a voter in hanover and a
complete supporter of access to voting
and again i think intuition
in-state tuition is a completely
different piece of an issue and it just
certainly does not apply to dartmouth
college thank you
thank you thank you ms nelson any
questions for ms nelson
representative barry
uh yes mrs nelson um especially part
about the college id
um
if these students are contributing as
much as you say they are and i have no
doubt that they are why shouldn't we
give them in-state tuition if they're
residents of this state and they're
contributing in their tax paying why
should they be denied the same benefit
that all other residents are
afforded
oh i'm not speaking to that i i don't
disagree or or have a particular opinion
about that my experience is primarily
with students at dartmouth college where
it's simply not an issue whether they
are afforded in-state tuition i would
think that that is a discussion though
for a i assume a different committee
that is looking at
uh sununu's plan to combine all the
in-state colleges the community colleges
tuition seems more appropriate to be in
that committee
this is as far as i'm concerned about
access to voting it's about
being patriotic it's about doing our
civic duty it's about being consistent
with what educators
try to encourage which is
students voting and knowing that that's
an important civic duty i'm sorry i just
realized my video wasn't on and so i've
popped that's all right thank you thank
you for your answer miss nelson further
questions from the committee
further questions from the committee
anybody online anybody there nope thank
you very much miss nelson for joining us
this morning
representative moffatt joins us uh
representative moffat welcome i don't
know if you heard but we are limiting
testimony to about a minute and a half
so welcome
roger then thank you madam chair
for the record i am representative mike
moffett uh merrimack 9 loudon canterbury
i am a member of the subcommittee
legislative subcommittee looking at the
usnh cscc snh merger uh very briefly uh
hb 429 is an important measure that
shines a light where it needs to be
shined if college students have bona
fide new hampshire residents
voting for new hampshire candidates and
new hampshire propositions that that
affect our state and communities and
they should be treated as new hampshire
voting residents and given in-state
tuition otherwise it seems like we're
fleecing these voting residents by
charging them out of state tuition
conversely if they are if they are bona
fide out of staters then
as evidenced by their tuition status
that we need to look at at that as well
whether they should be voting in new
hampshire elections or not i'm sure
there's something that's come up in this
committee in the past so anyway i just
encourage the committee to pass this
measure and get it to the house floor
so that the light can be shine on the
discussion of fuller discussion may be
held in a wider venue
and uh and then we look at doing the
right thing for
new hampshire voters getting new
hampshire in state tuition
thank you
thank you for questions from the
committee representative to rosen for
representative moffitt thank you madam
chair thank you representative for
taking my question
um the question was asked earlier to the
prime sponsor and he wasn't sure i don't
know if you might have more data as to
what other states
um
allow
college students to vote that are
still
for tuition purposes considered to be
out of state
uh do you have any numbers on what other
states allow college students to uh to
vote
uh thank you representative for the
question great question i i did not uh
research that particular
point or question i'm sure it's fairly
easily
easy to find on google uh you know
checking
thank you representative moffat for your
question further questions for
i'm not seeing any thanks for coming
over i guess if you say coming over to
the committee this morning on zoom
thank you for your testimony also signed
up to speak this morning was tom cronin
mr cronin
uh should be with us as a panelist and
mr cronin if you unmute good morning
good morning madam chair members of the
committee my name is tom cronin i'm the
director of government relations for the
university system thank you for having
us in this morning to speak with you on
this bill so the university system is
opposed to house bill 429 because of the
impact it will have on the cost of
public higher education for new
hampshire students and families there's
been some conversation about
in-state out-of-state tuition so quite
simply the legislature has granted the
board of trustees the authority to set
policy and determine eligibility for
in-state tuition rates at its most basic
our rules require two things one that a
student
or his or her family physically reside
in the state for at least 12 consecutive
months and two they have to reside in
new hampshire for some purpose other
than obtaining an education so you
cannot just enroll at a us 10 age school
move to the state and basically after
your freshman year apply for in-state
tuition you have to be here for some
purpose other than obtaining an
education and it's quite difficult
once you've started to sort of convince
the trustees in the policy makers that
you are here for anything other than
tuition if you've already started at the
university um a couple years ago a
similar bill to this one was introduced
in the state senate uh using the similar
this bill didn't ask us for a fiscal
note using the similar calculations as
we had done uh in 2019 uh the usnh
estimate is this would cost about 100 or
would be about 170 million dollar annual
loss in revenue to the system
and in response the system would be
forced to raise tuition and probably
reduce financial aid offerings um both
of which would have the results of
increasing cost of attendance for new
hampshire students
and i'd certainly also point out the
in-state tuition differential the the
fact that new hampshire residents do
receive an in-state rate is funded by
new hampshire taxpayers so to the degree
that uh we got rid of essentially any
barrier to receiving in-state tuition uh
taxpayer dollars would then be
distributed uh much more broadly i'll
stop there and would be happy to take
any questions
thank you mr cronin questions for mr
cronin
representative prudhomme o'brien
i have a question about
out-of-state students who are
the children of
professors at the university system of
new hampshire do they receive new
hampshire in-state tuition rates or do
they
pay out-of-state tuition rates
uh i would want to confirm this
representative but my understanding
would be if they are not new hampshire
residents they would uh still pay out of
state rates there is a
tuition discount for faculty and staff
so they would pay a discount on the out
of state rate not a discount on the
in-state rate representative barry
why is the university system advocating
to treat these new hampshire residents
that are attempting to put
roots down here why are we treating them
differently than all other new
hampshires why are they not the same
sure uh thanks representative i
appreciate the question as i said in the
testimony essentially
the the legislature has given the board
the authority to create uh in-state
out-of-state policies determine
eligibility there are two requirements
you have to physically reside in the
state for 12 months and you have to
be here for some purpose other than
obtaining education
further questions
anybody online
i thought i saw that representative
mirrorhead go ahead thank you madam
chair um
my according to my calculations sir um
there are 42 states that have residency
requirements of fewer than 30 days to
make someone eligible for voting do you
know
how many of those states connect the
residency requirements for
voting to the residency requirements for
in-state tuition thanks representative i
do not i'm sorry
thank you further questions for mr
cronin
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
for joining us on this this morning mr
cronin is lisa matthews with us if she
is rebecca coarser with us
is emily winfrey with us if she could
emily miss winfrey i thank you very much
for being here this morning and joining
us to speak on this bill if you on you
hi
my name is emily winfrey and i'm
testifying today as a resident of
newmarket as well as a student of the
university of new hampshire while i do
agree that granting in-state tuition
status to registered voters would
greatly incentivize voter registration
as well as civic participation i believe
that the amendment set forth in hb 429
and 432 would exclude and penalize
students who like to live in campus
dormitories as part of their college
experience
first year housing programs are designed
to ease new students into independent
living as well as establish a sense of
community and access to student
resources
as an out-of-state student from michigan
these programs were essential for my
educational experience at unh as i was
far removed from any existing support
system
i chose to reside and stay in
new hampshire
[Music]
but students like me would be forced to
choose between educational community
experience and civic participation in
your state of residence considering 96
of first-year students live in on-campus
housing
at unh this bill would greatly restrict
voter participation of university
students like myself
i do believe that the difficulty of
obtaining in-state tuition for
legitimate changes in residency needs to
be addressed as even living in new
hampshire for
really the entirety of my college
experience
i was still ineligible for in-state
tuition
i'd feel that these changes proposed
would do little in actuality to increase
thank you very much for joining us ms
winfrey does anybody have any questions
for miss winfrey
representative prudhomme o'brien
thank you madam chair
thank you ms winfrey for your your
time and your testimony today
do you believe that it was easier for
you to vote in new hampshire than it
would be for you to vote absentee
in michigan from michigan where you are
from
well even so i think it would have
probably been
as easy to get an absentee ballot but my
intention is and was to reside in new
hampshire um and with that being said i
would have liked to voted in new
hampshire
being a resident
thank you
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
for joining us is jules good here with
i'm not seeing mr good
from his good
um
representative horgan are you with us
yes you are
yes all right uh you're with us
apparently already so
thank you for joining us and we're as
you know we're doing about a minute and
a half so unmute and we're all
set okay good to be back um
uh and i did submit some written
testimony um representative paul disarro
mentioned his son who went to school in
maine i was in a similar position back
in a
very long time ago with my father served
in the legislature and i
when i was going to school in new york
state at clemson university i actually
uh did vote absentee because my dad was
on the ballot later i then went to grad
school at usc in los angeles and my dad
doing other things with lifestyle and i
actually immediately
registered and um
people of my polling place were glad to
see students come in so this is uh you
know people actually live in college
communities are actually happy to see
the students vote um the big problem is
i guess i have some written testimony
and i don't have to skip over some of it
and take more than a minute to read it
but first of all as mr tom cronin noted
this would throw the chaos of the
university into into uh
financing diversity into chaos you know
they should be encouraged to vote but
paying him
this should be a fifteen thousand dollar
a year uh incentive for
any students u.s citizen
who's not who hasn't been living new
hampshire to vote and that's a huge
incentive it's probably illegal too but
it was certainly for the chaos of
university into
uh
and then um into chaos and then the
board of trustees would have to prove
all these applications there probably
would be hundreds of them i'd probably
like almost every student's u.s citizen
would probably go that's a pretty sweet
deal just filling out a performance and
saving you know six thousand dollars
over four years um
and uh
it's also unfair to students who can't
register because they're under 18
because they're non-citizens and some of
those non-citizen students are in fact
residents of america qualify for the
so-called state tuition
unfair to students should communic
commute to uh
usnh or ccnh institutions from other
states the unh is one of several which
is actually located near a state line
and it actually is visa
representative horgan if you could
finish up that would be great and we do
have your written testimony as you
pointed out and you very conveniently
sent it as an attachment which was
actually very nice so thank you
pdf attached whichever i recommend to
everyone very nice
i have trouble with doc attachment but
anyway so this is uh
this is this is just a ridiculous bill
and certainly um
you know
it's uh probably illegal and certainly
just a terrible idea and it's also
unfair as i mentioned people who
go to a private school or
choose not to go to school you know if
you want to pay young people sixty
thousand dollars a year
move here that's that's fine that was
way outside the scope of what this
committee does and that's probably like
cost of that is unimaginable so anyways
this is a bad bill and i also uh all
right thank you representative horgan
for your testimony i think we've got the
idea of your position on this bill so
thank you for your testimony one other
thing one thing mr hall is and you're
awesome representative oregon does
anybody have any questions for
i'm not seeing any thank you for joining
us representative organ nice to see you
this morning i is mr barnes with us
mr barnes has signed up to speak
on this bill
and
i don't see him in attendance all right
i have a few people with their hands
raised again we're um
holding testimony on
if
i'm going to ask hannah dunleavy i
believe is how you pronounce your last
name you are with us if you unmute
welcome
to the committee in regards to hb 429 ms
dunleavy if you can
unmute
hi uh thank you for having me today good
morning madam chairman and members of
the committee
my name is hannah dunleavy and i'm a
student at dartmouth college
i'm here today to speak in opposition to
bill 362.
for years i've looked forward to my 18th
birthday october 2001 just in time for
the presidential election
when i cast my vote on november 3rd i
felt lucky to experience the feeling of
fulfillment and partaking of the
tradition of representation and civic
responsibility
my friends and i stayed up into the
early hours in the morning watching as
the results were called out in the
election in our dorms basement it was
exciting and meaningful for all of us
regardless of who we voted for
if house 360 house bill 362 would have
passed thousands of students would not
be able to vote new hampshire
a significant proportion of new
hampshire's voting population are
students as 74 of new hampshire is
registered to vote and 11 of new
hampshire are students
new hampshire would lose the
enthusiastic students driving voting
registrations campaigning for candidates
and advocating for the causes about
which they're passionate
my academic advisor is a new hampshire
state representative and i was proud to
vote for him this fall feeling confident
his love for state intelligence passion
and work ethic
yes these students could vote in the
states they grew up in for my friends
and me though new hampshire is becoming
our home we live here we study here we
work here new hampshire is where we've
discovered who we are and what we care
about we care about new hampshire and
our love of the state is reflected in
our desired vote new hampshire's
policies impact us more than states
where we grew up it is new hampshire's
mountains we see every day and climb on
the weekends we see their natural beauty
and environmental value and want to vote
to protect them we care about the new
hampshire communities we impact the
local communities and they impact us
we want our neighboring local local
businesses and neighborhoods to thrive
rallying around keeping businesses open
with their patients
thank you very much did you
it sounds like you're reading a very
nice tribute to how wonderful our state
is um but could you please wrap up in a
minute and if you have those the words
written down you could submit them
electronically
yes um please oppose this bill and new
hampshire will continue to benefit from
our enthusiasm commitment and love in
new hampshire through voting like every
voter we just want representation and
our wonderful government thank you for
your time and consideration of my
testimony
thank you very much does anybody in the
committee room have any questions for
miss dunleavy anybody attending
electronically
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
also with their hand raised is miles
brown
miles brown i believe you are with us as
a panelist if you unmute you can join us
and we have about a minute and a half if
you've submitted written testimony i'm
going to ask that you let us know or
other people who testify let us know we
have as i said received written
testimony good morning welcome
good morning chairwoman griffin i will
be brief with my statement here i want
to thank everyone for having me
my name is miles brown and i'm a college
student in new hampshire and i'm here
today to speak in opposition of house
bill 362.
uh governor sununu and secretary of
state bill garner agreed that we just
had the most secure election in american
history several measures were put in
place to ensure that registered voters
could cast their ballot safely and
legally right here in new hampshire
in the months since the election there
have been no substantiated cases of
widespread voter fraud in any of new
hampshire's 10 counties and yet
lawmakers in this state use lies of
voter fraud to advance legislation that
aims to limit eligible voters
constitutional right to vote this
rhetoric shows discord spreads
misinformation and can even incite
violence as we witnessed at the capitol
on january 6th in revoking our
constitutional right to vote you are
signaling to college students that we
are not welcome in the state you are
failing to defend the most fundamental
right in democracy the right to vote you
are failing to serve your constituents
college students across the state demand
to have their voices heard once again
you are failing to listen as college
students in new hampshire we live in new
hampshire many of us work jobs pay taxes
and rent houses in this state we are
valued and contributing members of our
communities and all we ask is that you
give us the opportunity to make our
voices heard i believe that every
student in new hampshire deserves the
right to vote and i hope you'll consider
what house bill 362 will mean for
thousands of college students who are
eager to engage in the political process
right here
i i am terribly sorry mr brown i was a
little confused by your testimony we're
actually on 4 29.
oh i'm so sorry chairwoman uh i think
that we've had a couple of people
testify as to
and we're hearing those comments and i
understand that that was the bill you
were talking about but i'm glad you
finally said it because you're not the
first speaker that we've had this
morning that i think has been saying
that one of the ways to track the
hearings for this committee and other
committees is if you're on a gallery
view
i don't know whether you get uh to see
the actual room
as one of the squares for example i'm
looking and i see election law and they
will actually try to have the bill that
we are discussing on the screen um this
is not the first time it's happened and
welcome and i understand that your
testimony would apply to 362.
yes i'm so sorry i saw that the hearing
was scheduled to begin at 9 45 so that's
uh
yeah i don't know if i could see the 429
when i wasn't a panelist so uh my
apologies oh all right maybe i'm about
to sneak on house bill 362 and i know
there are a big group of students that
are also hoping to speak on that bill as
well i know but keep in mind all right
thank you we'll address the testimony on
362 when we get to it thanks for joining
us all right
claire downey also has joined us
um and has asked to speak to this bill
um
i believe she's also speaking to 362 uh
madam chairwoman
all right miss downey if that's the case
i i am going to
move on to the next person who i had a
hand up which
was josh
colinas josh if you unmute we are on 4
29.
madam chairwoman i wish to speak on 362
as well
okay
so why don't you mute and somebody will
move you back to an attendee so i know
what's going on and look at that all my
hands have gone away then want to speak
on 429
again this is a problem with my
scheduling so thanks for your indulgence
also signed up to say a few words on hb
429 is deputy scanlan deputy scanlan if
you won mute you join us thank you
thank you madam chair members of
committee david scanlan deputy secretary
of state and i just quickly wanted to
make a comment on the voter id portion
of this bill
when voters go to obtain their ballot
they are already registered to vote
their qualifications have already been
proven to the supervisors of the
checklist and their name is on the
checklist
the intent of the voter id law when
obtaining a ballot is simply to be able
to identify that voter using the photo
on the id
to the individual whose name is on the
checklist
so by removing
college and school ids
as an acceptable form of id for that
purpose
the net result is going to be that
you're going to have qualified voters
going into the polling place that may
have no other
id on them in the college towns
and those individuals will end up
filling out
uh a challenge voter affidavit
uh and submitting that in lieu of just
simply showing a college id so i just
wanted to make that clarification madam
chair and i would be happy to answer any
questions
any questions for deputy scanlon
representative prudhommer brian thank
you madam chair
could they still use
these uh ids to
register to vote at their town hall
prior to the election i know my daughter
recently did that
this bill does not change any of the
requirements
to show proof of uh identity when
registering to vote so
if and i would have to look through the
statute but if
using a college id
as proof of identity to register is
i'm seeing none thank you for joining us
is there anybody else here who which
seeing i'm seeing none so i'm going to
close the public hearing on 429
um our next bill we've already referred
to is house bill
362. we are
a little behind on
a lot of the bills this morning relate
to the same things we saw how confusing
it was we have also received a
substantial amount of written
uh input on the bills that we're hearing
this morning i personally think we've
actually received the most
um on this bill
on these bills this morning rather than
any other bill
um testimony of right now i have
26 people signed up to testify on this
bill
if you have submitted written testimony
i'm going to ask that you refer to that
because i know a lot of you have
um we have received it
and we are going to be holding you to
about a minute and a half um most of the
people signing up for this have put down
a minute we're two minutes um so there
are a few five minutes and uh frankly i
don't
see that that is going to be
um
possible in regards to this so
uh this is house bill
362. relative to the domicile of
students for voting purposes
the prime sponsor of this bill is
representative silver
and he joins us and representative
silver if you can unmute i believe
we said was my i was trying
there you are good morning thank you
good morning thank you madam chair i'm
representative norman silber from
belknap county district two towns of
guilford and meredith
this is dealing with some housekeeping
uh on rsa 654.1 there is a subdivision
that specifically denominates that a
student of any institution of learning
may lawfully claim domicile for voting
purposes in new hampshire
in which they live while attending such
institution if domicile otherwise meets
the requirements of the prior section
basically
i'm seeking to repeal that section for
the following reasons
one of the basic one of the essential
principles of american law
is that we are all equal before the law
the equal protection of the law is a
very important principle in american law
and whenever we create a special class
of people a special favored class of
individuals
it diminishes the rights of others i
believe representative barry on a prior
hearing
indicated that some polling indicated
something like 40 percent of voters in
new hampshire don't trust the voting
system um any time we create a favored
class
uh of people particularly and as to
voting rights it diminishes the the
voting rights of other people if college
students meet the domicile requirements
set forth in the other rsas and by court
cases they are certainly entitled to
vote no matter where whether they go to
a state school or a private school
but to have a blanket provision
specifically singling them out as having
a special right to vote
really diminishes the rights of all the
rest of our citizens
it's no different than why don't we have
a uh for example a a section of an rsa
that says a uh blue-eyed people get
special rights to votes no matter where
how how long they've lived here or you
know what they do or whatever you know
you can you can do all sorts of absurd
type of things
but somehow or another we've created
this special class
of voters and it really is unfair to the
vast majority of voters if college
students qualify they qualify if they
don't qualify they don't qualify but
merely being a college student going to
school in new hampshire shouldn't be the
basis for
automatically being entitled to vote in
new hampshire matters
because i've tried to limit my testimony
to
my presentation to three minutes or less
i know you've got a lot of people on
this
probably mostly college students so i
would like to not take any questions
thank you
thank you representative silver for
joining us we do have a number of people
signed up
to speak on this bill
um and i am going to
[Music]
uh
ask if deborah nelson is here if on
still on the call if she could raise her
hand thank you very much
um and you
join us again here this morning welcome
if you can unmute i think we're all set
yes thank you madam chairwoman and
committee and i
am like miles brown probably someone who
spoke too much towards this issue before
when i thought that we were on that bill
so thank you for the clarification
but
again i do want to speak to this as a
resident of the town of hanover where
dartmouth college is located
and i want to counter that notion that
somehow we are creating a privileged
group because i think that's the way we
frighten people into
trying to shut down something to suggest
that someone else is losing when someone
gains and frankly
the right to vote is not a lose-win
situation we all have differences of
opinion about candidates that's not an
issue
of course one candidate will win and
another one will lose but what we are
really about it seems to me
is
equitable access to the polls
who are members of community to find
those ways that they can vote
dartmouth students contribute to the
economic well-being of this community
and that is true in other college towns
they support
organizations within the community from
the cancer center to the children's
hospital at dartmouth
they do research projects that benefit
small businesses they tutor students
they are vitally involved i and giving
them the right to vote
is about as american as we can be
it is saying
how can we make sure as many people as
possible
vote and are involved in our political
process to suggest somehow a false
equivalent thank you it's now
significant
a little bit i'm gonna finish my
sentence i'm just gonna finish my
sentence to have a false equivalency to
say it's like privileging blue-eyed
people or privileging the disabled
we can do better than that in having a
discussion thank you very much and i
oppose this bill
thank you for joining us and we do
recall your testimony on the previous
bill
um
questions representative terozian
thank you madam chair thank you man for
taking my question
in regard to your statement there if a
vermont resident because you're over in
that area comes into new hampshire
and um spends money comes into new
hampshire and works in the cancer center
and does these other things that some of
the students do but resides in vermont
should they be allowed to vote in new
hampshire
well you just made that point they
reside in vermont
and
they are usually much more concerned
about issues in the state where they
reside
dartmouth students are living here
in the state of new hampshire for four
years and
if they're going to graduate school even
longer so there there's i think you're
comparing
two different things
thank you with all respect further
questions for
ms nelson from people in the room or
thank you very much miss nelson also
signed up
on this bill is
bill kingston is mr kingston
i do thank you for raising your hand i'm
sort of getting this down finally at
this point in this the session as to
raising hands and mr kingston if you can
unmute yourself you are with us
madam chair members of the committee
the stated purpose of this bill is to
repeal the consideration of a student's
educational institution as his or her
place of domicile for voting purposes
disenfranchising voters is clearly
unconstitutional in order to get around
that the proposed legislation has to be
carefully crafted this bill fails to do
that
within the language of the bill are a
number of accepted proofs of residency
if this path if this bill passes all the
student has to do is obtain a document
and i quote
from a person who is listed on such
document or other reasonable proof of
ownership or control of the property
attesting that you reside at that
address signed by that person or his or
her agent who manages the property
in other words any person with some
level of responsibility such as a dorm
manager an elected frat house officer or
the person who signed the lease on an
apartment can attest to the student's
residence
the students who live at home and
commute to school will simply register
to vote in their home precincts
this bill fails in its intent and is
another poorly crafted bill that should
go nowhere i am opposed to this bill
thank you very much for your testimony
mr kingston does anybody have any
questions for mr kingston
in the committee room or
i'm not seeing any thank you for joining
us also signed up to speak on this bill
is
uh
um amanda
tole
you join us now if you unmute you are
miss toll you were with can you hear me
yup can you hear me
we can
awesome
honorable members of the election law
committee my name is amanda elizabeth
hole and i represent cheshire 16 which
encompasses the city of keene at large
i'm here today to testify in opposition
to hb
362. hb 362 will have a significant
impact on student voters serving to
disenfranchise them i represent many
keene state and antioch university
students and i care about their ability
to participate in the democratic process
as a community they contribute
substantially to both our economy and
culture and they deserve a voice in the
conversation about the laws and policies
that will impact them
our goal should be to expand access to
democracy
not to make it harder for folks to vote
i urge you to vote against h.b 362 and
against all other bills coming up before
you that attack student voting rights
thank you for hearing my testimony i'll
thank you very much for joining us this
morning i wasn't sure what you said does
anybody have any questions for
representative toll and i i apologize
that i didn't catch that you were
representative i'm
it's nice to have you be a part of this
body and i'm not i'm not going to take
questions but thank you very much for
hearing my testimony all right well
thank you very much
um a mr emmons i believe a norman emmons
has signed up to speak on this bill is
i'm not seeing
is
thank you very much
uh for raising your hand miss
you are with us and if you unmute
we
welcome good morning good morning uh
hello my name is heath howard uh i am a
20 year old uh college age student
from i've lived in new hampshire my
entire life
uh and one of the things that i really
wanted to bring up to your attention is
in 2017 sb3 was brought into law and
that dealt with an amendment to rsa 654
which is the same amendment or the same
uh
that hb 362 would be amending
so
in uh rsa 259 23
there is a definition of domicile
and
the the reason that uh sb3 was brought
up was to make it so that it matched the
definition in 259
so
why was there a
any discussion about changing it after
just
about four years now from 2017 to 2021
it makes
zero sense
that something that was changed to be in
line with one another would be changed
again to fit
so that students would be ineligible
this is a bill that is brought up for
political reasons
to prevent students from voting
and it is wrong based off of that
as as we know students live a minimum of
nine months a year that's august through
december and february through may
on in new hampshire
and they designate their their dorms as
a place of an abode and it's their
primary place of physical presence
so
since the definition of 259 is uh which
i'm using because
it will remain unaltered uh no matter
the outcome of the passage of hb 362.
um
would that domicile definition
as it states a natural person taking up
residence in a town or city within the
state and includes but is not limited to
occupying a primary place of habitation
does that not meet that definition
and in article 11
it's any inhabitant who is domiciled
here in the state has the right to vote
thank you mr heath if you could wrap it
up that would be great all right i
i didn't i have concluded
oh all right okay thank you um does
i'm not seeing any thanks for joining us
then
on this morning uh
i believe uh ben
cremer creamer
um has signed up to join us this morning
and
um you are with us
thank you and it's kramer just for the
for the right ramer thank you for that
it spelled word no worries
yeah good morning my name is ben i'm 23.
um i graduated from unh in 2019 i live
in newmarket now
i'm here to testify in opposition to hb
362 it's my goal to briefly share my
personal story to illustrate some of the
realities of being a modern young person
and a college student that this bill
completely fails to understand making an
undeniably bad policy
so to briefly share my story i grew up
in southeast connecticut it was a fine
place but a place i knew i did not want
to live after high school i made that
choice pretty early on 17 i got into unh
and i came to live in new hampshire for
the first time at 18. i was excited to
live in a new place and get to know a
community as an adult for the first time
2016 election season rolls around that
was quite the experience for me being
new to new hampshire as i'm sure you all
know the special time on the
presidential election year is in new
hampshire and i voted for the first time
ever in my life being just 18 um in that
2016 election on election day i
registered
um day of in person to vote in durham it
was fast easy satisfying i was excited
to do this in a new place i called home
and i'm sharing the story to share that
like the experience of being 18 and 19
and moving from your hometown for the
first time is one that thousands of
people in the state are currently living
and one that you members of the
community might share or had shared at
one point i would challenge you to think
back to that feeling when i was 18 i had
made the choice that i was not going to
live where i grew up but i had no idea
where i wanted to live instead the only
thing that was certain was i would spend
more than nine months of my next four
years living in new hampshire
um
and potentially longer than that you
know if it took longer to finish my
degree or if i wanted to stay here after
like i had chose um and still live here
when it came to voting i was i
understood that i was being asked a very
basic question do you want to
participate in the governance of your
community my answer was yes and the
community i wanted to participate in was
obviously the community i was now living
in for the vast majority of my year
yeah i left new hampshire during some
summers to work that's a normal thing
that people do people have to work jobs
in the summer to be able to afford to go
to school here that's fine normal people
travel for work all the time sometimes
it's extended periods of time
it seems to me the question that bill
asked is essentially should students be
able to vote in new hampshire or
presumably be forced to vote in the town
that they were last living in or not
vote at all if my parents had moved
while i was in college to a completely
new place where would i vote then
i would not have an address in
connecticut
why is it mr kramer
if you could wrap it up that would be
great yeah i'll make my last point um
why is it more correct for me to vote in
a town in which my parents live and not
the town in which i currently live
there's no other time we consider
someone's previous address to be more
important than their current address for
this the intention of this bill is to
improve the quality or function of new
hampshire elections it simply does not
accomplish that the intention of this
bill is to disenfranchise young people
and change the electorate for the gop's
political gains have the decency to be
honest about that either way it's bad
policy
and we should oppose i would urge every
committee member to oppose this bill
thank you
thank you for your testimony mr kramer
does anybody have any questions for mr
kramer
i'm not seeing anybody thank you for
joining us mr kramer also signed up to
speak on this bill is that helen
barkworth
is helen barkworth with us
if she could raise her hand through
the wonders of the electronic platform
we are on
and ms barkworth i do see that you're
good morning
my name is helen barkworth i am a
resident of east hampstead new hampshire
and i am testifying in opposition to
i am testifying in opposition it happens
to all of us miss bark with it's okay
the dog i'm testifying in opposition to
hb 362.
i was a freshman at the university of
new hampshire in 2016.
it was my first time voting in any
election as i had just turned 18 years
old
i was 50 minutes away from home and in
an unfamiliar environment
however the community that i found at
unh made it so i never felt alone in
that historical election
freshmen are not allowed car access on
campus and i could not always count on
my parents to be able to drive that long
distance especially because election day
is not a holiday in this state
had it not been for my ability to
register in the town of durham for
voting i would have missed some of the
most vital elections in the past four
years
we are brought up to understand that our
right to vote in the us is sacred
we are taught that it is one of the
things that makes this country great
when the officials in office write up
bills that make voting more difficult i
struggle to believe the legitimacy of
the values we were taught as children
if voting is all the adults in our lives
told it told us it was then that right
must be given to us in full with no
restrictions that would make it less
accessible for some of us
this bill is furthermore both classist
and ableist it completely excludes
groups of people who are not able to
access off-campus voting and i
wholeheartedly oppose this bill i will
not be taking questions
thank you miss barkworth for joining us
i also have signed up to speak on this
bill
ken barnes is mr barnes with us this
morning
he was able to be with us on friday i do
not see him here this morning
is
jose or josie pinto with us here this
morning
and i apologize for not being certain
how to pronounce the name thank you for
joining us on the electronic platform i
believe if you unmute you should be able
there welcome again to election good
morning good morning and it's josie
pinto i'm a resident of dover and i'm
here on behalf of new hampshire youth
movement testifying in opposition to hb
429 as well as 554 and 362.
i urge you all to not make it harder for
students to vote here in new hampshire
whether you realize it or not these
attacks send a strong message to the
young people who are choosing to live
and pursue their education here in new
hampshire that their voices aren't
welcomed and that our state doesn't want
them to participate in our democratic
process
the fact is new hampshire is already the
highest exporter of young people in the
country and we need to be doing
everything we can to ensure young people
are able to invest in a future here
getting involved in politics can be a
pathway towards young people growing
their personal stake in living here and
as people who spend the majority of
their years here they deserve the right
to vote and participate in issues that
would directly impact them this is often
the first time they've come of eligible
voting age and that means it doesn't
make sense for them to vote in a state
they've never been involved in the
politics of
i know when i went to college my mom
took the opportunity to move to another
state so with this bill that would have
left me without a place to vote at all
is that really what we want for people
who are newly coming into the ability to
participate in our democracy
i urge you all to do everything you can
to make our state more equitable for the
young people who live go to school work
and want to see a future for themselves
here please vote itl on these bills and
otp for hb 538 our democracy is
strongest when we all have a fair chance
of being part of it thank you for the
time
thank you josie for joining us again
here at election law does anybody have
any questions for
ms pinto
i'm not seeing any so thank you thank
you also
also signed up to join us this morning
is
rachel horn
miss horn i believe you are with us if
you unmute
welcome to the committee and the hearing
on hb
362.
yes good morning madam chairman and
members of the committee thank you so
much for having me today my name is
rachel horn i'm a student at dartmouth
college and i'm here in opposition of
house bill 362.
as a student at dartmouth college i am
an active member of the hanover
community from going to restaurants to
forming relationships while hiking with
other new hampshire residents my life is
directly bound to new hampshire and
every day dartmouth students give their
energy and resources to the hand of our
community and not to have a voice in how
the town and state are governed
students should be treated as equal
members of the state regardless of where
we grew up we all live in hanover now
receive mail in hanover recognize
hanover as our home out of love for this
community we deserve the right to vote
here
in a state we love so much
as the home of the first presidential
primary new hampshire is a unique place
to engage with politics young people
eager to get involved with american
governance are attracted to new
hampshire for this very reason but
without student voting rights aspiring
politicians and change makers lack the
incentive to move here new hampshire's
motto live free or die speaks to the
importance of voting rights to live free
is to have a voice in how you live
voting grants students the opportunity
to live free in their home state thank
you for your time i will not be taking
questions
thank you very much for your testimony
okay uh also signed up to speak
is uh
joshua calian kalionis i believe
uh again i hope i pronounced your name
correctly let me see if i can find you
under the attendees
um
raise your hand please oh there you are
okay i see you
yes i'm here uh good morning and thank
you for the opportunity to testify my
name is josh calianos and i'm here in
opposition to hb 362. i'm a dartmouth
student and new hampshire taxpayer as
you know new hampshire supreme court
requires the private universities in the
state pay property tax and god knows
that bill is passed on to me through
tuition
i'm also here to say that my choice to
live and work at school is no different
from the choice to rent an apartment or
home
this bill tells students that their
rights conferred by residency are
contingent on who their landlord is this
distinction is critical and meaningless
because students who choose to live on
campus are no more or less connected to
the state than those who sign a lease
we all have a set graduation date
i'm here to testify because my
experience over the last year shows how
unwieldy the new law will be
last spring i rented an apartment in the
state for the first time i was not
enrolled in classes and i worked at a
firm in hanover at the height of the
pandemic i signed up to be a disaster
relief worker through new hampshire
response for all intents and purposes i
was not a student at the time
yet i remained registered to vote here i
went to virtual town meeting you got the
idea
however had i needed to change my voter
registration this january when i moved
back into on-campus housing this bill
would have said i am no resident
seriously mr silber tell that to my new
hampshire driver's license and car
registration
tell that to my disaster relief
this bill draws a meaningless
distinction between on-campus and
off-campus housing
it attacks those of us who live on
campus who have the longest remaining
tenure in the state because those are uh
frequently the youngest students
i think the transient's explanation for
this bill is completely wrong and i
asked mr silver to state a valid
explanation for this bill before
thank you mr galliano's uh taking
questions i will
any questions for mr kalianos
some members here in the committee room
or online
i am seeing none so thank you very much
for your testimony thank you
okay also signed up to speak is kelly
zeilman
are you with us
xylem
hey ms eileman i've just promoted you uh
if you are new you should be able to
speak
good morning um
my name is kelly and i am a
college student in new hampshire i'm
here today to speak in opposition of
house bill 362.
i am a us citizen and over the age of 18
which gives me the right to vote as a
college student i don't have one place
where i live the entire year but new
hampshire is where i spend the most time
out of anywhere and it's where i call
home
my freshman year i spent the fall the
winter and the spring in hanover new
hampshire i spent the summer working in
texas and maybe cumulatively
a total of a month
in connecticut where i grew up
um during breaks my sophomore and junior
year have been interrupted by covid but
i'm still going to spend more time in
new hampshire than any other place i
don't own a house in new hampshire and i
don't have a car registered here but
that's because i'm 20 years old and i
don't have those things in any other
state either
but i live in new hampshire i work in
new hampshire and the laws of new
hampshire affect me by taking away my
right to vote new hampshire you're
taking away my right to vote because i
don't have somewhere else that i
feel like is the place that i live
um thank you for your time
thank you miss allman
okay
it's not
also signing up to speak is miles brown
mr brown let me promote you to a
panelist
hey mr brown i believe you if you unmute
thank you so much for having me today i
already spoke uh earlier and read most
of my testimony but i will just conclude
with the final few paragraphs here
uh in revoking our constitutional right
to vote uh this committee would be
signaling to college students that we
are not welcome in this state you are
failing to defend the most fundamental
right in a democracy the right to vote
you are failing to serve your
constituents college students across the
state that demand to have their voices
heard but once again you are failing to
listen as college students in new
hampshire we live in new hampshire many
of us work jobs pay taxes and rent
houses in this state we are valued and
contributing members of our communities
and all we ask is that you give us the
opportunity to make our voices heard
new hampshire is my home that is why i'm
here today
i believe that every student in new
hampshire deserves the right to vote and
i hope you'll consider what house bill
362 will mean for the thousands of
college students who are eager to engage
in the political process right here in
new hampshire their home thank you for
your time today
thank you are you taking questions
uh yes i will
any questions for mr brown
in the committee room or online
i'm seeing none thank you mr brown
okay also signed up to speak is
sophia
okay and again i just apologize if i
are you you're you've been promoted uh
you've unviewed it go ahead
thank you uh good morning members of the
committee and thank you for having me
today my name is sophia bokai and i'm a
student at dartmouth college i'm here
today to speak in opposition of house
bill 362.
this bill promises to take away my right
to vote in new hampshire quite frankly
it is absolutely egregious that this
body seeks to silence my vote my voice
i came to the granite state in the fall
of 2020 eager to participate in the
electoral process new hampshire is my
home for the foreseeable future i will
spend the vast majority of my time in
hanover my primary legislative advocacy
will be focused on new hampshire
politics yet this bill will steal my
right to vote for the candidates i
support here whoever they may be
i have only voted once in an election
and i did so in hanover new hampshire
using a ballot with the new hampshire
state seal at the top and i can say with
absolute certainty that that moment in
which i exercised my civic duty for the
very first time was the highlight of my
year
the pride i felt when handing my ballot
to the town clerk was enormous not
simply because it was my first time
voting but because i was voting for
candidates i cared about
students like me who are domiciled at
their college or university are not
ignorant of new hampshire politics nor
careless with their vote
i voted in new hampshire because i care
and because i am deeply concerned about
the policies that affect me and my life
here and if the intent of this bill is
to deter those like me who are informed
and careful with their vote well i
respectfully urge you all to reconsider
the bill's merit as citizens of the
united states we should all be actively
involved in uplifting voices not
silencing them this bill treats voting
like a privilege but it is a federally
mandated right and i will continue to
fight for my right to vote as long as it
is threatened here in new hampshire my
home
thank you for your time and
consideration of my testimony
thank you ms bokai any questions from ms
volkai
many members here in the room or online
thank you very much
thank you
also signed up to speak is claire downey
ms downey i see you've got your hand
raised and it appears you've already
been promoted to panelists if you are
new go ahead
hi yes thank you um my name is claire
downey and i'm a student at dartmouth
college i'm here today to speak in
opposition of house bill 362. i believe
that voting is one of the most important
parts of the democratic process and the
best way to have our voices as citizens
heard i am passionate about the state of
new hampshire where i am proud to live
and attend college and i know that i'm
able to make change for this state
through my right to vote during my time
at dartmouth it has been an incredible
experience to get involved with politics
in new hampshire and see how the
policies here affect the lives of
citizens every day casting my ballot in
new hampshire in the 2020 election was
an incredible experience as i understood
the power of my vote and the real change
it was going to affect the process of
voting in new hampshire was incredibly
accessible making it easy for me to
exercise one of the most important
democratic american processes
i believe that it is essential to
protect student voting rights to uphold
the values of freedom and democracy that
are so essential to the new hampshire
spirit i will not be taking any
questions today thank you for your time
okay also signed up to speak on this
bill is a hannah dunleavy
i already gave my testimony but i would
like to reiterate
how important new hampshire is to
dartmouth students
um it is our home it's where we work
where we study
where we're discovering who we are and
where we're making our friends
i urge you to oppose this bill so that
new hampshire can continue to benefit
from our enthusiasm commitment and love
for new hampshire through voting like
every voter we want representation and
our wonderful government
thank you for your time and
consideration of my testimony
mr chairman can i just interject briefly
to um to let you know that
representative sandler has just joined
us she had some technical issues but she
is here now and you may want to do uh
her attendance
oh sure um
i'm madam clark can you handle it thank
you very much
okay uh also signed up to speak um i i'm
assuming the previous uh
ms zen levy was not taking questions
um
jack jacqueline grampy
are you with us here today to speak on
i'm not seeing her
my
michael shannon
are you with us today
there you are well thank you for joining
us
um i have hopefully hit the right button
so that you can join us with audio if
hi um i am here as a student at plymouth
state university to oppose testify to
oppose this bill
so voting is one right we have as
american citizens to participate in our
democracy
as an out-of-state college student
taking away my ability to vote in the
state that i spend
basically all of my time
shows how careless and out of touch you
guys really are i live in this state
shop in this state and i take advantage
of everything it has to offer
and this really makes me feel as if none
of that matters and you're kind of just
using me for my money
allowing out-of-state students to vote
is necessary and
we really should um have a voice in the
community that we reside in thank you
thank you for joining us
um mr shannon i don't usually like
questions but i would like to ask you
one
um
why is it that you described yourself as
an out-of-state student do you live here
or do you live out of state
i am from connecticut and go to school
here
thank you
i'm not seeing any so thank you for
joining us also signed up to speak on
drucker dow drucker you have joined us
and if you unmute i think we're all set
good morning madam chairwoman and
members of the committee
my name is doug drucker and i'm a
resident of durham and a current
graduate student at the university of
new hampshire and i urge this committee
to oppose hb 362. i also want to extend
my opposition to both hb 429
and 554
as a lifelong resident of new hampshire
this legislation may not impact me
directly but it will impact many in my
community as a college student member of
the unh community and someone who deeply
cherishes our democratic process this
legislation disturbs me
as an undergraduate i had the privilege
of living with my parents in new
hampshire to save money on college costs
as a graduate student i began renting an
apartment in durham where i am currently
registered however not everyone has
afforded the same economic and familial
privileges as myself
as off-campus housing prices skyrocket
students are left with few housing
options outside of on-campus dormitories
additionally not everyone has the luxury
of affording a vehicle that they can
then register
not only does this bill discriminate
against the youth vote but it
disproportionately targets students who
are economically disadvantaged by
prohibiting educational institutions as
a student's place of domicile for voting
purposes
this legislation is nothing more than a
desperate attempt to concentrate
political power and purge youth voters
from participating in the democratic
process
instead of discouraging student voters
in the state there needs to be more of
an effort to provide adequate voting
resources that make it easier for
college students to participate instead
of attacking students interest in civic
engagement we should be rewarding it
college students are an integral part of
the broader granite state community and
they deserve to be recognized as such
thank you for your time and i will not
be accepting any questions
thank you very much that was dow drucker
speaking in regards to his opposition on
362 and some other bills that we're
hearing here this morning also
uh also signed up to be to speak this
morning is eric
heinrich i am sure i did not pronounce
that correctly and thank you very much
for joining us
uh electronically and i believe if you
unmute you will be with us with
if you want mute you'll be with us
thank you there good morning chair
griffin vice jim mcdonald and honorable
members of the election law committee i
speak to you in opposition of house bill
362.
also 429 and 554
but specifically 362 which strikes the
use of an institution of higher learning
for establishing donuts aisle
obviously creates a weird special
treatment of dorms apart from all other
rental properties in the state
if we rent a dorm on our college campus
that would be our college address
but in regards to residency how is this
room any different from any other room
rented in the state we still live and
work in the state we spend large sums of
money in this state
through this investment of time and
money we create jobs join churches
contribute to civic organizations and
participate in the community of this
state just like every other resident
to put this law in a different light if
my parents were to live in new hampshire
but i attended school in texas except
for winter break and the odd summer
vacation i could still vote in new
hampshire and influence the laws while
only being beholden to them for a few
months weeks a year
meanwhile a student who lives here could
see their right to vote stripped away
it's not as if we're sneaking across the
connecticut river in the dead of night
to collude with the little old ladies in
the clerk's office
i also hear a lot of talk about how
we're gonna spend four years here but
that denies that many of us plan to set
our lives down here and spend far longer
why should we be treated differently
than any other resident in the state
new hampshire needs more young skilled
and devoted residents as are attracted
to the state's institutions of higher
learning there's a powerful choice on
the part of a student to choose new
hampshire as their home and establish
domicile
now we are faced with a powerful choice
of whether we should disenfranchise
these very members of the community
when i first arrived in the state i was
proud of the motto live free or die the
strong message of values convictions and
determination not only to protect our
own rights but all those around us
if i live work here and attend church
contribute to tax revenue and choose new
hampshire as my home beholden to all of
our laws and yet i'm deprived of
electoral influence over those laws i
think that's nothing short of tyranny
and i urge you to give an unfavorable
report on house bill 362. thank you for
your time and if you have any questions
i'd have to answer thank you for
speaking and thank you for taking
questions does anybody have any
for mr i like
how do you pronounce your last name i'm
sorry i'm sure i'm sorry uh hernowitz
horowitz
thank you
thank you anybody have any questions for
mr hurwitz
i'm not seeing any thanks for joining us
this morning
um also signed up to speak this morning
on this bill was lisa matthews
if lisa matthews is with us could she
grace
grace murray also signed up and miss
murray uh thank you for
negotiating our electronic system i
believe you are with us and if you
unmute
uh welcome to the election law committee
thank you
um good morning um
thank you so much for having me i'm
grace murray a student at plymouth state
university um i believe voting is an
integral part of our system
it gives the residents the chance to
have their voices heard
voting is the best way to assure the
community's wants and needs are being
represented
students live at their school we take
part in the community we visit the local
businesses and we pour our money into
the economy
we have a right to have our voices heard
in the community we live in
i live in plymouth yes i go to school
there but i also know the locals
i love the town and i support the
businesses
college students are residents of the
town it's our home
taking away the right for members of a
community to vote is morally
reprehensible
we pour your coffee we bag your
groceries we serve your dinner
college students whether they previously
lived out of state or not are an
important part of the community and it's
about time that that was understood
students deserve a say our voices will
demand to be heard we deserve a voice
and we deserve a vote thank you
thank you very much for joining us this
morning miss murray does anybody have
anybody attending electronically have a
question
i'm not seeing any so thanks very much
for joining us
uh david millman
has signed up to speak
this
this morning uh and he joins us this
morning and i believe if he unmutes he
there you are mr millman welcome
sorry i have my i have a wrong
background on sorry about that well wait
a minute now i have to ask what are you
running for uh i'm running for uh
hannover select for but this is not um
relevant to my testimony i would be
regardless um thank you to the chair and
members of the committee for allowing me
to testify my name is david millman and
i am because of the location a dartmouth
student um i understand i appreciate the
timing concerns so i just want to give a
very quick testimony against the bill
um
i love this country and i really believe
that one of the most patriotic things
someone can do is to vote
uh when i walk around my campus and see
the american flag i
i feel pride because i know that we in
this country stand for democracy
it's my civic duty to engage in the
political process of my community and i
know this is exactly what countless men
and women have fought for
make sure that every vote voice is heard
whether those voices are popular or not
this bill reveals a section that
clarifies the right to vote
that section is not about creating a
separate class of voters but making sure
that everyone who lives here has the
same opportunity to vote
i'm a college student and i have the
honor a select number of students in the
country have because right now i'm able
to call new hampshire home
i vote here because i care about the
state i urge everyone present to vote no
on this bill and any other similar bills
there's also i believe a public health
consideration because i think that this
bill would make it harder for college
students to get the code vaccine
eventually
when inventory allows in phase 3b
but that would
not having that clarified would
encourage unvaccinated students to
travel across the state rather than
being vaccinated in their college
um i'm open to all questions uh but
honestly you'll probably not get um
technical satisfactory answers uh thank
you for your time
thank you does anybody have any
questions for mr millman anybody
attending electronically
all right mr millman before you go
though i want to tell you good luck on
your race i was on a board of selectmen
for 12 years have you been on the board
or is this your first time
this is my first time thank you all
right well
if you make it after a couple of months
i'd love to hear from you to find out
what you think
all right well i hope this bill doesn't
pass because then i will not be able to
i will not be able to run
if that's if that's an additional
consideration of the committee
thank you
okay
i'm not
sure i understand that but maybe we'll
talk about it in executive session thank
you
um again i have a samantha paquette
signed up to speak on this bill
and
i am not
seeing her i do have representative
horrigan and representative balducero
with hans ray oh i'm sorry um
henry clementowitz had signed up to
speak on this bill mr clementowitz are
you here
there you are thank you i'm i'm sorry uh
i almost missed you so welcome to
you're with us
yes um good morning uh members of the
house election law committee my name is
henry clementowicz and i am a lawyer
with and a lobbyist for the american
civil liberties union of new hampshire
which is a non-partisan nonprofit civil
rights organization
i'm not going to uh repeat any of my
written testimony so instead i thought i
would just respond to
a point made by
the prime sponsor of this bill in his
testimony and
rsa 654-1a
in fact does not create a special class
of voters for college students and that
statute was recently interpreted by the
new hampshire supreme court in may
in casey versus gardner and
the new hampshire supreme court
determined that what that every college
student
who registers to vote like every other
every other person who registers to vote
um
meets the same residency obligations as
anyone else
uh in the state and so
the meaning of the statute has been
interpreted and it does not put special
solicitude
on college students to be able to vote
in fact um
hb 362 would would do the opposite
because so many before me have said
uh it would remove
as a consideration for domicile purposes
um the maintaining of a college dorm
address so
um i'm happy to take questions um if
there are any and i and i refer the
committee to my written testimony as
well thank you very much
any questions from committee members in
i'm not seeing any thank you mr
clementowicz for joining us this morning
representative porgin i see that you
have your hand up if
you unmute i think you will be
representative horgan i think you are
unmuted if you want to proceed this is
house bill 362.
yes i know i'm i continue to be
represented timothy oregon i continue to
represent stratfor district 6 the towns
of durham and madbury and um
i
like to send in written testimony in pdf
form but you probably don't receive it
so after you're already there um
the question that came up well my main
point is students have the same voting
rights as any other citizens as uh
attorney clement philbin said by the way
we both uh for those years apart we both
went to the same uh
undergraduate college columbia
university in new york city and we both
had parents who were in the legislature
at the time but i don't know how
whether he voted in new york city or in
in
nashua but uh
certainly um there were even back in the
mid 70s there were many uh
students on campus who were registered
to vote at their on campus addresses it
was allowable in new york state and
actually every state back back then it's
been away since the voting rights law in
the mid 60s and uh at columbia actually
even had a polling place on campus which
didn't just serve the campus also some
of the surrounding community but yes
that's nothing new so
you know students have the right to vote
the community to live attending a local
college university is as valid a reason
as any other from moving to a community
and as
other people have pointed out uh
most students vote and do other things
you may do they don't spend all their
time going to school
so an on campus or off-campus student
dwelling is a good place as any
uh live it's as well as any other place
where people may live and also a college
is also a time when students develop new
lifelong habits and voting is a good
habit so we should be encouraging them
to vote
finally and as you mentioned under both
federal and state law students have the
right to vote where they live
that's been the case uh
well especially since the voting rights
law but in new hampshire even before
that and uh
i'll mention two landmark federal
decisions on the 1972 neuberger versus
peterson case uber actually was a
student at dartmouth college and
peterson was water peterson the governor
that was a dartmouth student who had no
back home thank you representative
horgan that is a much cited case here in
the election law committee if you could
wrap up that would be great and i know
it was in your pdf
and also mentioned the sims versus
united states decision that finally if
it's a good idea there's a drafting
error it takes out rsa 654 1
comma
roman numeral 1 along with uh
roman numeral 1a so that um
not sure why why was written that way
but i'm opposed to the bill so it's a
move point for me but
if you do go forward you might want to
look into whether that was the right way
to draft it so anyways um i'm richard it
thanks
thank you if there's
any questions for mr horrigan for
i think that is the correct it's the
overall paragraph and then the sub
paragraph but we can certainly look into
it
um thank you for testifying also with
patiently with their hand up
is rep
representative al baldicero
representative balducero you should join
us
as be joining us as a panelist
unless i've hit the wrong button
representative baldusaro if you can
unmute
okay i got it there thank you madame
chief uh madam chair this is
representative albal the sour rockingham
county district five
uh which is londonderry i'm glad i got
an opportunity to sit here and listen to
all the testimony
and when i get out of the testimony here
that the students or they get special
privilege
and as a 22 year marine who lived in 78
states
i was required to vote absentee ballot
when i say required meaning we have a
voting officer in every unit that you go
to and you you vote in your
um
the state of your home record
now if i when i get out of the minecraft
move to new hampshire i was required to
change my
um tax farm everything because of uh by
the federal law your home or record is
where you pay your taxes to
okay and if you go to a site called
fvap.gov
it gives veterans
regulations on how to vote um and what
to do
if you change your voting uh residency
to another state you have to fill out a
form and it has to be on your loan even
earning statements veterans in the state
of new hampshire we have thousands of
them they're required to vote at the
home of record unless they change over
and make new hampshire their state home
a record and then they have to supply
support fill out new farms everything
there for tax purposes and for a home a
record for when you get out where to
send all your items to now i have a son
who's stationed out in california in the
marine corps right now he's in kuwait he
took the time and voted absentee ballot
okay from kuwait his wife lives in
california stationed there he took she
took the time and voted absentee ballot
for new hampshire because they are
residents of new hampshire
but yet they had a vote absentee ballot
we are setting up or we have set up in
the state of new hampshire a separate
class of people
okay and students want to be special
privileged people that don't live in the
state they're non-residents
then they you either become a resident
of the state of new hampshire or like
the military the thousands that live in
new hampshire that some of them even own
homes but yet they maintain their home
record
so that when they get out they're paying
taxes to the home of record
that that is where they vote
thank you representative
if you could wrap it up that would be
great well thank you ma'am chad this has
to be this law has to be fixed one at
all so everybody is playing on the same
sheet of music and that's all i have
thank you
i'm not sure what that band would sound
like but it would be a lot of fun i
think
all right any questions for
representative belvisaro
from members here in the room or
attending online
no thank you and thank you again
representative baldur sarah for your
patience as i try to deal with people
who have actually signed up ahead of
time
first and and then go to people who have
joined us
uh mr barnes now joins us he had signed
up earlier when i called uh he was not
in attendance but he is here now mr
barnes welcome to the election law
committee we have been asking people to
summarize if they've submitted written
testimony and to keep their testimony to
about a minute and a half thank you
great i will do that and uh madam chair
thank you for allowing me to play in
i i want to
speak in opposition and ask you to itl
this bill and also 149 508 the bills
that
seem to treat
college
students as a somebody other than
uh the rest of us who live and
do all of our life things in new
hampshire
they happen to be students so what they
do in new hampshire for four years is
they live and study and
perhaps work a part-time job
but they're just like the the rest of us
who live in new hampshire and you
there's no guarantee that
people are going to
stay in new hampshire people who move
from
oklahoma to new hampshire for two years
and then decide to move to maine
while they're in new hampshire
they vote in new hampshire when they
move to maine they vote in maine
these students you know when i was
17 i went to college so
the four years that i spent in college
were
only about 20 less than 20 percent of my
life
and then i went to grad school
and
voted in another state and that was a
similar number of years small percentage
of my life and then i moved elsewhere
had a job
and voted there and then i
moved to new hampshire and i've been
voting here for 30 years
i don't think the students who are here
for four years
and they're here wholehearted you know
they're they spend their life here uh i
don't think they're any different and
they should be able to vote the same as
the rest of us so i just would ask that
the committee think
uh in terms of the reality of the lives
of
students who are here some of them
choose to stay here forever
some of them like me go to grad school
someplace else but
there's no reason for them not to be
treated like everybody else who lives
here works here plays here
etc thank you very much and i ask you to
itl this bill
thank you mr barnes does anybody have
any questions for mr barnes
anybody attending electronically have
i'm not seeing anybody with their hand
up thank you mr barnes for joining us
um
also attendee with their hand raised is
sue russell i'm going to ask if anybody
else wants to speak on this bill if they
raise their hand after miss russell
um
deputy scanlon has patiently had his
hand up on this so i'm going to go to
deputy scanlon and then we'll go back
to attendees miss russell i believe you
have joined us and if you unmute we
am i unmuted
you are welcome okay great great i've
already written my testimony my comments
on the various bills i'm sue russell i'm
in newbury new hampshire
and i'm a supervisor of the checklist
all i wanted to do is clarify
on one of the speakers before
you have to be a registered voter
to run for any office
so that's what he was talking about
if you are not a registered voter you
cannot run for a town office or a state
office so just wanted to clarify that
for the committee and that's it because
i've already done my written testimony
thank you thank you thank you miss
russell for the
written testimony i know you submitted
and thank you for clairing that mr
millman said that at the end of his
testimony and i wasn't sure he
i'm not i wasn't sure about the
statement so thanks for clarifying that
deputy scanlan uh
thank you for your patience and
uh
you should be all set to join us i think
thank you madam chair members of the
committee i'm david scanlan deputy
secretary of state and i will be very
brief
i just wanted to point out uh in house
bill 362
uh on line two and representative
horrigan already mentioned this but
part of what's being repealed in this
statute is rsa 654 colon one roman
numeral one and that is
a part of the statute that talks about
voter eligibility generally
it's not specific to college students
and i don't think it's the intent of
anybody to have that section
repealed
the second comment that i would like to
make is that section two of the bill
addresses language that was put in the
statute under senate bill 3.
senate bill 3
is currently being
litigated
due to
constitutionality of that statute
and so the uh the provisions in section
two are currently
uh unenforceable they're they're
enjoined by the court
so uh i would uh suggest i guess that
before we amend that portion of the
statute we wait until
the court uh makes a final decision
on whether that law was was
constitutional or not
i'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you deputy scanlon for clarifying
that i apologize to committee members
and members of the public i was aware of
the fact that that was just represented
to you by deputy scanlon that provisions
of the law that were changed by sb3
are enjoined though technically on the
books
so um some of the requested changes uh
create some process issues in regards to
what's going on so thank you for that
clarification any any questions for
i'm not seeing any i do have two people
who have raised their hand
uh quincy
abramson has raised their hand to speak
on this welcome to the election law
committee this is house bill 362.
if you unmute you should be with us
welcome
um thank you so much for letting me
ask a question slash respond really
briefly my name is quincy i live in
i don't know what that was
i graduated from the university of new
hampshire in 2019 and was around when hb
1264 was up in 2018 and just wanted to
respond
to representative baldessaro and say
that
after listening to many people's
testimony
i do not know how he
made this a matter of laziness
this is not a matter of laziness or a
refusal to vote absentee or an inability
to vote absentee miss abramson just to
sort of keep things moving in the right
direction we try to focus our comments
on what we want to say about bills not
what we think somebody else might have
said that was
um
inappropriate that many people might
agree or disagree on but thank you okay
keep going
yes no i would just say then that um as
a college student it's you know an
interesting time
for your identity and figuring out where
you want to be and what you want to do
with the rest of your life um
and you're navigating difficult things
with your family with your finances and
all of those things and you're just
trying to make your voice heard in your
community and i don't see any reason why
people should not be able to do that so
thank you
thank you miss abramson voting is making
your voice heard in your community
is there anybody here in the committee
room or attending online
who would like to ask i don't miss
abramson a question i think she's
great i don't
um
thank you very much for joining us and
also with their hand raised is sophia
i
i'm going to just ask you to unmute
um
and join us and ask you to pronounce
your last name because i don't want to
be completely rude this morning welcome
sophia
all right can you hear me we can perfect
um well thank you for taking my
testimony today my name is sophia it's
pronounced beyond a lilo i'm 14 i live
in manchester and i'm speaking today on
behalf of the new hampshire high school
democrats in opposition to hb 362.
i'm opposed to hp 362 because it would
violate students constitutional rights
to vote in this state while they are
domiciled here
the new hampshire constitution states
that any inhabitant of the state 18
years or older is eligible to vote and
that an inhabitant is somebody who has
domicile here
well i understand there is some
confusion about the exact meaning of the
word domicile i think it's fair to say
that somebody who spends the vast
majority of their time here should be
considered to live here
anyone who lives in the dorms at a
college is spending the majority of
their time in new hampshire
during the almost 10 months of the
school year covers students sleep here
eat here and get their educations here
during those 37 weeks they contribute
tens of thousands of dollars to new
hampshire's economy through their
tuition they pay taxes on all the same
purchases as other residents and they're
in their paychecks here
so for all practical for all practical
purposes college students in new
hampshire are residents we should not be
attempting to disenfranchise them by
refusing them the right to proper
representation in our elections
by trying to suppress college voting
rights we tell students in new hampshire
that they are not valuable and do not
deserve to be considered part of our
state and i think it's only right that
we give them what they are
constitutionally guaranteed and allow
college students to vote in new
hampshire by enabling them to establish
domicile so i thank the committee very
much for their time and urge them to
recommend itl on hb 362.
thank you very much for that testimony
does anybody have any questions
here in the committee room or attending
online
i'm not seeing any so thank you very
much for attending the hearing and being
online and
good luck with high school and your
organization
is there anybody else in attendance who
would like to
give the election law committee of the
house some their comment on house bill
362.
i'm going to close the hearing on 362. i
don't see anybody as i stated this is
one of the bills that we received a
substantial amount of written testimony
on and for this bill and the other bills
i'd like to thank everybody for doing
that
our next public hearing i will open it
is 508 establishing
a committee to study the definition of
temporary as it pertains to residents
in the state of new hampshire
representative tarosian is the prime
sponsor and we'll speak to the bill and
i'm going to ask that he can just stay
at his
um seat uh we're in a different room
today we don't we're set up a little
different and i think that will work
terrifically so representative teroshian
if you want to press i think the red
button so you can leave it down
will be all set thank you madam chair
and good morning to the rest of the
committee members of the election law
committee uh for the record i'm
representative peter trojan i represent
rockingham county district 14 which is
the town of atkinson and plaistow
this bill originally was going to be a
bill to
define what temporary is because it's
it's really not defined right now and
speaking with several people we couldn't
come to a
uh
a conclusion exactly what that should be
i i think it should be one year but
anyway so so we decided to go the
the
committee route to
ascertain
what temporary means in regard to
that term used in voting and the reason
i
brought this up
during the 2020 election
the attorney general's office
had put out a statement that for any
any college student
that was
not in the state physically
had attended say unh or plymouth one of
the new hampshire colleges
and they were not physically coming to
the state to go to school but they were
doing zoom learning
had the right to
pull an absentee ballot and vote in the
state of new hampshire you could only
had to take
one semester of classes
in fact technically it didn't even say
you had to be here physically taking any
classes
so i contacted the office and asked the
question um
how can that be
and i was told well they're temporarily
out of the state so my next question was
well
what is the
term or what does the the
you know define what temporary is in
regard to a time frame
and the answer i got was there really
isn't one
so
own property in new hampshire or not
and have your company
theoretically assign you to another
state to work
you could claim you're there temporarily
be a temporary on a temporary basis
and never come back into the state for
years and it's still considered that
you're a new hampshire resident so it
seems to me we should have some kind of
limit on that so this what this um
study committee attempts to do is to
come up with a consensus of what makes
the most sense now granted there should
be exceptions for example
members of the military um
expats that are out of the country for
extended periods of times we we should
have a caval for that but i believe
uh for the rest of what seems to happen
right now there should be some kind of
definition for it
so it's it's that simple i hope you
support uh going to the study committee
so we can come up with a with a firm
definition of what uh temporary is in
regard to voting
with that i'll take any questions the
committee may have on the subject
thank you representative teresa and
thank you madam chair um
two questions um
is this film aimed more at
people who are temporarily residents of
the state or is it aimed more at
defining those who are temporarily
as it were outside the boundaries of the
state that claim residency in the state
that's the first question the second i
guess is
my understanding that federal law
regulates the durational residency
requirements for
offices like the presidency and the vice
presidency
um is this
is this that would this study group be
aiming at defining temporary with
respect to only statewide
thank offices
no no this all right thanks for the
question representative so know that
this um would define temporary as it
pertains to somebody that is a stated
new hampshire resident but that is out
of the state for ex extended period of
time and so
what the attempt is here is to define
what that means so if you're out of
state for six months for whatever reason
um should you have the right to
vote here certainly if you're out of the
state for ten years or more never
sitting sitting foot back in the state
most people would probably say no that
wouldn't be allowed so this attempts to
find a
you know a reasonable number there in
calendar months or calendar years if you
want to put it that way so it pertains
to somebody that's a resident here now
or or claims to be a resident that in
actuality has been out of the state for
representative
we need you to unmute we can't hear you
all right
any other questions from anybody here in
the committee
or attending excuse me for the
pretending online for representative
teresan
i'm not seeing anything is there anybody
else in attendance i don't have anybody
i'm not seeing any so i'm going to close
the hearing on 508
and i'm going to open the hearing on
5 5 4 and i'm going to step down and ask
my vice chair
to
continue with this hearing because i
will be introducing the bill
okay a little procedure to hearing on
post bill 554 and i recognize the
sponsor representative
thank you
chairman donald
my name is barbara griffin i'm a
representative of hillsborough 6 out of
goffstown and
i present to the committee for their
consideration house bill 554
um like the previous speaker
with house bill
508 i became aware that there was an
issue
in regards to temporary residence
when as we all know due to the covet
pandemic people who use
uh facilities in the state for
parts of the year primarily the issue
arose quite honestly in regards to
student attendance um we're not back in
the state
attending school
albeit for some or part of the year so
it did raise the issue generally as to
what's a temporary resident
i will tell you in the past i am aware
that people who own vacation homes in
other states have called our secretary
of state's office and said well hey i've
got a house out there
up in the white mountains can i vote in
your elections in new hampshire yeah i
have a license in california and live
here but can i vote there those
questions have
occurred and that it then
i thought that perhaps it was time to
address it
a little more clearly in regards to the
statutes
in consideration of what was going on it
appeared that there should be some
tangible
location that was tied to somebody
maintaining a domicile you've heard
discussion this morning about the
recognition of college dormitories or
other
places certainly i think many of us have
an apartment or house that we use as
the uh point of connection to the state
of new hampshire to claim that we are
appropriately here for voting so what
you see in house bill 554 is my attempt
to define that i was not aware of the
house bill 508 when this was being
drafted
um and perhaps
what the committee might consider in its
deliberations is if indeed a committee
is formed to study this issue
um that in in that case perhaps 554
should be retained to be able to deal
with the recommendations of the study
committee
um and
with that um i am done and would be
happy to take
questions any questions for
representative griffin from committee
members here in the room
any questions from those participating
online representatives
thank you uh thank you mr chair and and
thank you representative i just
um
just looking at the language changes
i'm i want to clarify the the core
intent for instance take
line
um 12
of the first page of the of the of the
bill where it's where it lives is
crossed out and maintains a physical
presence is substituted
um
what's the
both of those seem sort of i don't know
synonymous to my
i guess
non-lawyers
eyes
what's the bill getting it with that
kind of substitution
well i
i think that that's getting at the
vacation home from the person in
california who
has um
a nexus to the state but doesn't in in
fact really maintain a physical presence
to the exclusion of anything else here
um so that's where i you know
this state has spent countless hours
debating the terms inhabitant domicile
and
um
resident
and
it's been the subject of constitutional
conventions actually so
we hear in hearings a lot people using
the word live
and at some point i think we need to
recognize that maybe in some of the
statutes trying to nail it down a little
more would be helpful maybe not but
thank you thank you very much
further questions for representative
i am seeing none
thank you representative griffin thank
you
okay we have uh several people signed up
to testify on this uh the first one
and i
i'll try to pronounce them correctly
representative griffin did an excellent
job earlier clementowitz i believe it is
and um envy clementowitz
from mentors i will uh get to
upgrade you to panelists
mr clementowitz i think i just came to
the rescue for you so if you unmute you
um good morning members of the house
election law committee again my name is
henry clementowicz and i am a lawyer
with and a lobbyist for the american
civil liberties union of new hampshire
and i'm here to testify in opposition to
rsi 554
um i'm sorry hp 554. so uh there's two
points that i i want to make
uh the first involves the changes on
page one
lines twenty
through 28
um which make two uh language editions
both of which um
uh talk change the common law definition
of domicile that um regarding an uh a
temporary absence or an absence from
domicile before a new domicile is gay
and so i i lay out in
my written testimony how
i think there are um there's a group of
people who might be prevented from
voting anywhere
by the change that adds um except when
the physical location of the domicile is
no longer related to the person either
by virtue of lease or deed or physical
presence
um and so i think that you know
to the extent that there are people who
are prevented from voting at all by this
change in language i think it's uh a
pretty clear constitutional violation
i also
sorry
um
i also
wanted to point out that uh 2018's house
bill 1264
which changed the definition of resident
under the motor vehicle code to align
with the definition of domicile
um
i wonder if that would no longer be the
case um
if this bill becomes law and the
definition of domicile is changed
there's some discussion
in the casey versus gardner case from
2020 where the new hampshire supreme
court examines rsa 654-1
the common law definition of domicile
and the definition of residency under
rsa 259
and i had understood that a large
portion of this body was interested in
making those two definitions the same
and i wonder if this change would no
longer do that and so sort of undo the
i'm i'm sorry i didn't hear that could
you wrap up um we're limiting time on
the testimony sure sure i just have one
more point to make which is about the
last
um sentence that's added in
on page two lines seven through nine and
i addressed this more in my written
testimony
but by adding this language about a
person who maintains
um a domicile address in another state
and is eligible to retain that domicile
not being
eligible to gain domicile in new
hampshire i think you know
number one that's probably already the
law because domicile requires
a person established a primary physical
place to the exclusion of all others but
number two to the to the extent that it
changes the law at all i think it really
just introduces more ambiguity because
it doesn't really discuss what it means
to be
eligible to retain domicile
when domicile has a subjective component
so um so we oppose this bill for the the
constitutional and and policy reasons
that i i also identified in my written
house very much
sir thank you questions for for this uh
individual from the yes mr trojan
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you sir
taking my question so we got to the the
first question you had on
um
the line 21 area the way i read that is
with the language changes that if you
don't have a domicile here or you you
own a piece of property that might have
been a domicile that's now leased out to
somebody else so you're not living there
and you're out of state for
a period of time that you wouldn't have
the right to vote
with that in this state would that is is
that the um concern that you have
somebody that's that
is not domiciled here and not living
here should have the right to to vote
please help me understand i'm not quite
clear on your opposition
absolutely so um i don't think that that
requires that a person go out of state
and so i use in my written testimony the
example of a person who
grows up in manchester
establishes domicile when they turn 18
by becoming a you know a big fan of the
fisher cats and you know deciding that
elm street revitalization is the most
important thing to them
they then go to unh at durham where they
live but they don't establish domicile
because it's no longer it's not their
primary place for participating in
self-covering but then imagine that
their parents sell the house in
manchester and move to nashua
um and and the student in question has
never been to the new house in nashua
well
under this law they wouldn't be allowed
to vote in manchester because they're
not connected there by deed they
wouldn't be allowed to vote in durham
because it's not their primary physical
place for participating in democratic
self-government and they wouldn't be
allowed to vote in nashville because
they've never established a physical
presence there and so that's why
the common law definition of domiciling
again this is discussed in the casey
versus gardner case from our court last
year
has a provision as the current law does
that domicile once created
is maintained until a new domicile is
established so i hope that answers your
question
representative
other questions for the uh
mr clementowitz
anyone online
seeing thank you very much sir thank you
mr kingston is here if you want to
okay also signed up to speak we have
mr kingston you are with us as a
panelist
yeah he's there i need to ask him to
unmute
mr kingston
i'm going to move on to the next person
mrs barnes
thank you mr chair i will pass on this
and save you all some time
okay also signed up to speak is rona
bean
this beam
adam chairman
i don't see her
i do not sit on a beam
and finally the final person who has
signed up to speak this morning is
norman emmons
all right so i'm promoting lucas meyers
okay uh
other attendees who wish to speak is
lucas myers mr myers i believe you've
been upgraded to a panelist
you wanna
yes thank you uh uh mr chair and uh
madam chair as well um good morning my
name is lucas meyer i'm here testifying
uh on my own i will be brief uh henry
clemento has covered most of what i
wanted to address
but just wanted to echo some of his
concerns
that it feels like almost every session
we are changing the definitions of
domicile and residency creating great
confusion
amongst voters in this state and i'm
particularly concerned about the last
the changes in section 2a that last
sentence there
and i think continuing to move the goal
posts on voters in the state as to who
is defined as eligible to vote in the
state
creates a great deal of confusion um
which can act uh to suppress uh eligible
voters from taking part uh in our
elections um and with that i will
leave it there in the essence of time
happy to take questions
any questions from mr meyer
anyone here in the committee room or
seeing none i will move on thank you mr
maya thank you
representative beldacero has been
promoted
okay and also who um someone with a hand
raised who's asked to speak and testify
is representative alba de sado
representative balbasaur go ahead
uh thank you uh mr chairman and um uh
first of all representative al balder
rockingham county district five
i want to thank representative griffin
uh for bringing this bill forward this
is long overdue
but what i'm the reason i've been
holding on uh staying on with the
election lawyer is to make sure
that the veterans are protected
in in this law here because they are
like me when i went out somewhere for
three years i was temporarily there for
three years and then moved to another
base for three years sometimes a year
and a half two years so i want to make
sure that uh there is something in there
that protects those veterans there like
my son who was stationed in kuwait
uh who was temporary there and then he's
gonna be back in california
but his home record is here at my house
so that's all i have just to make sure
that these veterans in new hampshire are
protected thank you
thank you representative
any questions to representative aldesal
representative o'brien thank you mr
chair
uh i have a question
i know that there are a lot of uh former
foster youth in the military
and if they age out of the system and
join the
military's if they
would have an address that they may not
have enough say let's say an emotional
connection to anymore would they be
protected under under this bill
yes uh they they should be protected uh
under the bill here because
when you join the military
you have what's called the homer record
give you an idea when i was in the
marines my parents sold their house
okay
and moved up to new hampshire they sold
out of massachusetts but because i was a
resident of massachusetts i was still
able to use that address
um of my homer record because that's
where i joined the marines from
so you you are protected
for a federal uh you know government
wise
thank you
any other questions for representative
baldocaro
anyone in here in the committee room or
online i'm seeing none no open democracy
action is asking just oh i'm sorry that
was questions go ahead thank you
representative
thank you
i'm also our requesting to speak is um
has been promoted yeah
okay uh open democracy action is asking
to speak
you could state your name please for the
record
i'm sorry that uh it came across as open
democracy action i'm brian beal i'm
deputy director of open democracy action
uh i wanted to speak in opposition to hb
554.
good morning madam chair and members of
the committee i'll be brief um
i will
hit the last four
paragraphs or five paragraphs of my
written testimony
just for brevity
when the question of temporary absence
was raised last year prior to the
election the new hampshire attorney
general's election division and new
hampshire secretary of state's office
issued a statement on august 19 2020.
quote once a student lawfully
establishes a domicile in new hampshire
under rsa 654 colon one the student does
not lose his or her domicile due to
temporary absence
rsa 654 colon 2 states a domicile for
voting purposes acquired by any person
in any town shall not be interrupted or
lost by temporary absence they're from
with the intention of returning there to
as his or her domicile
common sense would dictate that those
registered voters have every intention
of returning to their domicile upon
subside these uh subsiding of the
pandemic if they have not returned
already and how is this different from a
new hampshire employee working an on a
state project for six months or a year
wouldn't they too be disenfranchised the
question of domicile and temporary
absence from it has been asked and
answered by a republican-led new
hampshire attorney general's office hb
should be voted inexpedient to legislate
thank you again for the opportunity to
speak madam chair and to the members of
the committee
thank you mr beale any questions from mr
dale this morning members here in the
committee room
any questions from those participating
remotely
but what's the last name hi
yes go ahead please hello
uh thank you um very much long segment
guys statement up here thank you
chairman griffin and uh as someone who
lives in goffstown it's good to meet you
um it's good to be here with you all my
name is phil tregoni and i'm a senior at
saint anselm college uh and i urge you
to oppose hb 554.
originally i'm from stone and mass but
i've been proudly a resident of uh
goffstown uh for over two years and a
registered voter
i maintain a physical presence here and
i have been
making many connections in the area
shopping at local stores and i've become
familiar in the town in any way that a
a person familiar with the area should
be
i live in goffstown a vast majority of
the calendar year and uh under hb 554
people who should theoretically be able
to make their voice heard in this
community students like myself could
face higher barriers of voter
registration
i was a plaintiff on league of women
voters at all versus william gardner at
all a case that fought against very
similar legislation to hb554
while i have massive respect for
secretary gardner i completely opposed
what he was trying to enforce
before the 2018 midterm elections
students in my position were
experiencing a bureaucratic nightmare
filled with confused administrators and
town election officials it took me
personally 45 minutes in the goffstown
town offices to get registered despite
being the only person there because of
how confusing it was
if it was this difficult for me someone
who's politically engaged and willing to
take a large chunk of a monday morning
to testify before the legislature
picture how many students who are
perhaps more apolitical must have
decided to call it quits on voting
this may sound like a good thing to some
people but a college or any institution
of learning as described by 554 may be
the only location a student can be
present for during an election as we've
heard many examples of this morning
i hope while you consider this bill that
you remember my testimony and many of
the other testimonies today and consider
the rippling effects on political
participation that 554 will have on new
hampshire's students and that you make
the correct decision to oppose it uh
thank you very much
thank you mr orgoni
any questions from mr agroni from many
members here in the room
any questions from those participating
remotely
and i am not seeing anyone else uh
asking to speak this morning
so with that i will close this hearing
on healthcare
554.
thank you vice chair mcdonald for taking
over for me on that bill at this time i
will open the public hearing on 531
this is relative to determining the
qualifications of voters and
establishing a provisional voter
registration
and provisional ballots the prime
sponsor
of this bill is
representative lynn
representative lynn if you could raise
your hand i know you're with us i'm
unless somebody's already promoted you
i'm not sure where you are
thank you very much for joining us this
morning
um i believe you are with us and if you
unmute we will be able to hear your
representative
yes
thank you very much madam chair and
members of the committee
this
my intent
in uh
uh proposing this bill
is to do away with the system or at
least originally it was to do away with
the system
of um
of affidavits and and i know uh
representative abramson who may be on
the line has
has i think suggested an amendment
uh to the bill which which
would reintroduce the issue of
affidavits but i'll let me let me sort
of go over
my original purpose first and then uh
um
his uh suggestions i'm not particular
i'm not necessarily saying i'm opposed
to them um in fact it may it may be that
they make that they make good sense but
let me sort of take a moment just to
tell you
my what my original intention was in in
drafting this
as you know under current law
we have a what i would refer to as a
voter identification
we have voter identification
requirements
light
and what i mean by that is that
there are
various provisions that say you need to
provide identification
um you need to provide some form of
proof
of citizenship age and domicile
but
if you don't have that proof then you
can just say so you can just swear that
it's true
even if you don't have that proof and
this is particularly becomes a problem
where for people who are registering
uh on election day
so what this um
and under the current
what under the current law particularly
for people who are registering on
election day
they
uh they can say well look i don't have
any evidence of my domicile as an
example
um and are permitted to vote
and then the law sort of establishes a
procedure
whereby
the the uh the secretary of state
is um is allowed to do some sort of
after the fact verification
um
in an effort to establish whether the
person is telling the truth uh was
telling the truth or not
um
uh it seems to me that that's very
awkward unlikely uh very
uh uh to be successful
um and and just uh
creates a huge hole
in the voter identification system so
what this bill is designed to do is to
say we're going to stop that
um there will be you don't you don't get
to say
um as an alternative to providing the
proof
of the
uh of the
citizenship age or domicile
uh that uh simply an affidavit that's
that says i swear that that all those
things are true
rather you have to do those things
you have to provide the proof
and uh particularly with respect to
domicile
what it says is that if you come in
uh within 30 days first of all if you
come in with
more than 30 days to register then then
you have to provide the documentation
and if you don't have it at the time you
first come in then you can provide it
later but but before the the day of the
uh
of the election but what it's
particularly designed to cover is the
situation
of someone who who arrives on election
day
without any proof of uh to establish
those things
and says i want to vote
under the under the proposal in my bill
what would happen is
the person would be permitted to cast
a provisional ballot
um
which would uh which would be clearly
identified which he would then put in a
he would go vote vote in secret put it
in an envelope
um uh which would be sealed so nobody
would know who the person voted for
and then the person would have five days
after the election to provide the proof
that that the person
should have brought
to the election but didn't
if the person provides the proof
then the provisional ballot will be
counted will be opened and counted along
with the other ballots if the person
does not provide that proof
then then the person's ballot would not
be counted
um
i've done some research and you know
into
voting laws and the constitutionality of
various provisions i think this
provision would be
would be completely constitutional as i
understand it
the u.s supreme court has said that
voter identification
uh uh laws and uh
are constitutional and and there doesn't
need to be something like
you know a provision where you can
simply
if you can't provide the proof of the
things that you need to provide
in order to establish your eligibility
to vote that you can simply swear that
it's true
and that's enough i think the supreme
court
um
uh
has indicated that that that you know
there there does not
um there does not need to be such
uh such an exception you can have voter
identification laws that actually have
real teeth and it seems to me that
that's that's all this bill does
and uh and i i i think it makes sense
and i i hope that the committee will
agree
and we'll uh will recommend it off to
pass and i'm happy to take questions
thank you
representative lynn
questions from committee members in the
room questions from people online
i'm not seeing any
thank you for your testimony on your
bill this morning
uh
i thought i saw a hand raised myself
wait a minute do i i i you know i sort
of do the right to left but you know
there are days the head doesn't go quite
so far as it probably could
so um is there any representative lane
there you go i see you now thank you
hopefully you can hear me this time i
think i
um
thank you uh for taking my question uh
have you talked to the secretary of
state uh about this bill because it
includes provisional ballots and is
something that historically we've not
done in new hampshire
um and and gotten their input on this
i have not and i would and um
you know i i think that
getting the input of the secretary of
state would uh would would be a good
idea i have not i have i should say i
have heard
that um some people have expressed a
concern that the provisional ballots
would create um an issue because
there's a provision in the constitution
i believe in the section dealing with
the state senate if i'm if i'm
remembering correctly but i may be wrong
on that i think it's in the section
dealing with the state senate
about about votes being
um
on election day
um and some suggestion that well this
you know provisional ballots might
create a problem
um with that but
i i don't think that the provision
um is required to be read that way and
and
more importantly
if if you really had to have
the the complete outcome of the election
on election day and you could never
do anything after election day then the
whole process of having recounts and the
whole and the provisions that we have in
the law allowing recounts
um and you know
uh just to uh
to change the result of an election if
there's been an error would not be
allowed and and and clearly the law does
allow that so i i don't think that
um
that that the use of provisional ballots
which would
you know which would would uh
allow the the the final results of an
election to be delayed by no more than
five days which is
probably less than
than uh the delay that's caused by the
typical recount
um would would uh
would bring into question the
constitutionality all right
thank you representative mooney thank
you
thank you madam chairwoman and thank you
representative but your answer to the
last question pretty much covered my
question so i'm going to withdraw my
request for a question thank you
representative murhead
thank you madam chair i'm just wondering
if you you have data on
how many um
affidavits are are used in a in an
ordinary election season
i'm sorry i don't i really do not have
uh that information all i mean other
than really very
in a very vague sort of uh you know
anecdotal way i've heard a number of
people say that
that there are too many of those but but
you know if you ask me for any detail i
have to say honestly i don't have that
any detail
thank you sir
thank you
further question something on that one
i'm not seeing any
thank you
as i said representative lynn
um in regards to this
bill i have ken barnes has signed up to
speak on this bill mr barnes if you want
to speak could you raise your hand i'm
not sure you're still with us
there you are
we are
talking about hb 531 and we are
eliminating testimony this morning to
about a minute and a half so thank you
okay thank you madam chair and members
of the committee
uh i wish to speak against
the
bill proposed by my friend bob lynn um
he's eloquent as usual but i think that
what his bill fails to take account of
is the
um
the reality that i've seen in
the many elections where i have been a
poll watcher
and the provisional affidavits have and
provisional ballots and the affidavits
have worked just fine it was seamless it
was not uh it didn't seem to me anyway
to be in any way burdensome to
the clerks
it
people who came to register for the
first time at the polling place were
able to do that people who did not have
the ids that were necessary
they got a provisional ballot they
signed the affidavit and they went and
voted didn't hold anything up it was a
perfectly
fine process
and then
the the votes were counted so i
i don't know
if it ain't broke i don't know why we
would try to fix it
um having said that
i
also
think that
there is
the constitutionality
of the or possible lack of
constitutionality
that representative lin was talking
about is
uh not doesn't even become
relevant if
uh
if if
this works he says it's constitutional
maybe it is
but in any event i don't see why you
would disenfranchise people
who show up at the polls and
uh god knows all of us have at one time
or another forgotten our
i don't know our health insurance card
or our
credit card or
whatever it is a driver's license uh
somewhere out in the car
maybe in your glove compartment and you
know here you are after waiting in line
to vote
you're at the front of the line and you
don't have it with you i don't know it's
it's
really doesn't seem to be
a problem in need of fixing and i think
if uh
representative lynn checked that did the
last question asked about numbers i
think if you check the numbers are not
all that uh great
that they would have
swayed any elections
thank you mr barnes if you could wrap up
your testimony that would be great
that's it uh please ipl this bill
does anybody have any questions for mr
barnes
online or
electronic i'm not seeing any so thank
you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
maureen uh bren brent tripp
uh miss brent tripp if you're in
attendance if you could raise your hand
that would be terrific
um it doesn't look like you're with us
at this moment also signed up is a limit
elizabeth
um
amila
elizabeth if you are with us i apologize
for what i just did to your last name
um i'm not seeing you a rebecca corser
has signed up to speak on this bill if
you're in attendance if you could raise
mr kingston
has signed up to speak on this bill mr
kingston if you could raise your hand
that would be great
and apparently somebody has told me that
you're already with us so welcome mr
kingston thank you madam chair members
of the committee
uh
this bill poses as a fair bill and it
pretends to put an end to unfounded
allegations of voter fraud in new
hampshire
the problem i have with it is there is
no voter fraud in new hampshire and the
restrictions to it seeks to impose are
unconstitutional
if you pass this bill there will be a
number of lawsuits that should tie this
up in court this is a clear abusive
legislative power and i urge you to
thank you mr kingston for staying with
us this morning and joining us on this
build does anybody have any questions
online or in committee room i'm not
seeing any
uh
mr clementowitz has also signed up to
speak on this bill
thank you um members of the yeah i wish
i knew how to do it miss russell you
seem to go on mute and off mute and i'm
not quite sure why you're on our panel
but if you could just mute that would be
great thank you go ahead mr clementowitz
thank you um uh members of the house
election law committee again my name is
henry clementowicz and i'm a lawyer with
and lobbyist for the aclu of new
hampshire uh i certainly appreciate um
the schedule and i will do make every
effort to be concise but i would beg the
committee's indulgence
um given the number of things that this
bill does and so i i will try to go
quickly but there are a number of points
worth making because this bill is a big
bill that has a lot
so the first thing that this bill does
is it would eliminate the qualified
voter affidavit which is used by people
who are
proving identity age or citizenship when
they're registering to vote uh according
to a right to know request then that i
got from the secretary of state's office
and in response to representative
meerhead's question
on november 3rd 2020
637 people used this affidavit to prove
identity and 816 people use this
affidavit approved citizenship
and the secretary of state's office does
not count the number of people who use
this identity affidavit to prove age so
that's 1400 people
who registered on november 14th who did
not have the requisite documents to
prove
one of the qualifications and so had to
rely on this affidavit and who would not
have been able to vote
were this bill
law
in response to the constitutionality of
this
provision i think there's
that's a really important question and
not an open question
in uh over the summer in fish versus
schwab the 10th circuit considered a
very similar documentary proof of
citizenship regime in some ways it was
actually more
i'm sorry less restrictive than this
bill
um and ruled that that statute was
unconstitutional under the anderson
burdick framework and then the us
supreme court declined to review
that determination
uh just this summer with the the current
composition of the court and and
basically the reason for that is
under this law
anybody who doesn't have a passport
birth certificate or naturalization
papers with them would not be able to
register to vote because there's no
other proof of citizenship that's
commonly available
and there are there's just a lot of
people who don't have that documentation
and they would be prohibited from voting
turning next to the provisional ballots
piece
which was discussed a little bit by
representative lynn the prime sponsor
i attached in my written testimony for
you a brief from the secretary of state
and attorney general where they
discussed their belief that part two
article 32 would prohibit
i think by fair inference provisional
ballots there was a case uh brought over
the summer aft versus gardner seeking to
extend the deadline for receipt of
absentee ballots from must be received
by election data must be postmarked by
election day and basically what the
attorney general and secretary of state
told the superior court judge just like
six months ago is that they believe that
violates the state constitution which
requires that all votes be countable and
counted on election day
um and so i think the same logic would
would show
that creating provisional ballots
would be unconstitutional under part 2
article 32.
another important point about it thank
you mr clementowitz if you can wrap up i
did recall that you submitted written
testimony and we have received it thank
you
i appreciate i i'm just going to make if
i made two two points and i'll make them
very quickly
in addition the provisional ballots
and provisional registration i think
puts new hampshire's exemption from the
national voter registration
act at risk which is if you look at the
fiscal note a concern raised by the
secretary of state as well
because our exemption is premised upon
there being a state law in effect since
1993 that allows every person to
register on election day and i think
there's a open question whether the
justice department under this
administration would find provisional
ballots
um prevent some people from registering
and thus would cause us to lose our
exemption
and make us have to comply with motor
voter and i know the committee is
very familiar with all that that entails
and then the final point and again i'll
make this as quick as i can
is
this would this bill would completely
change the way that challenged voters
are dealt with by um making it so that
if
uh a moderator deems well founded any
challenge no longer will a person be
able to vote there's no provision for
due process for
presentation of evidence an opportunity
to be heard an opportunity to go to
court and any case where a person is
just straight up prohibited from voting
if they're eligible to vote i think
would be
uh struck down by court very quickly
because obviously you have a fundamental
constitutional right to vote and so i
think
that the procedural safeguards in place
there are are completely inadequate and
um so those are the the three reasons
why i think that this bill would violate
the state and federal constitution and
i'd be happy to take questions thank you
for your indulgence madam
i'm not seeing any let me just check i'm
not seeing any so thank you for joining
us on this thank you
so signed up to speak on this is leslie
smith
leslie smith if you were in attendance
if you could raise your hand that would
and with that i have recognized
everybody that had signed up to speak on
this bill this morning um i see that and
if anybody else would like to speak
um olivia zink is with us and she would
like to speak on this bill
madam chair you uh selected brian beal i
believe and i think olivia did want to
testify
um for our organization
i actually clicked on olivia so hi i am
here um this for the record my name is
olivia zinke i'm the executive director
of open democracy and i'm coming to you
from franklin new hampshire where a pro
voter pro-voter
pro-democracy organization and i am a
registered lobbyist
i have concerns that this bill ends
same-day registration as i understand it
and
in true new hampshire fashion new
hampshire picked same-day registration
because it was the cheapest option
and
the 1993
passage of the national voter right act
does
have forced new hampshire to choose
either having the same day
provisions or motor vote voter
and i think this committee has debated
this for a long time and decided that
same-day registration is the thing
that is the best
for new hampshire
um this bill also ends the practice to
sign sworn affidavit
you have seen a superior court judge
strike some of these burdensome
or
you know any any other burdensome
documentation for registering to vote
and i would urge you
i know that that court is that case is
still being litigated and i urge you not
to make any changes um to these
affidavits until after that procedure
has finished
also house bill 30 531
allows for provisional ballots
i urge the committee to read new
hampshire constitution part 2 article
32.
the piece of this is that all ballots
must be counted in a public meeting
um after all the ballots are closed the
moderator calls to end the
the
close the polls
um my understanding if you pass this
you'll require moderators to keep pull
that continuous meeting for five days
i think it's hard enough to find good
moderators and selectmen
and other people but if you require them
to sit there for five days until people
prove um their identity i think that it
will be very hard for you to find poll
workers willing to do that
um and for many other reasons i hope you
vote inexpedient to legislate on house
thank you for that testimony does
anybody have any questions for
ms inc open democracy action
i'm not seeing any here in the room i'm
thank you for coming
this morning to testify on house bill
is there anybody else in attendance that
would like to speak on hb
531 i'm not seeing anybody so i'm going
to close the public hearing on 5 31.
the next scheduled hearing this morning
is
38.
oh no what am i skipping 5 35
i did i apologize to everybody i was
flipping a little too fast here 535 is
relative to the qualified voter
affidavit
um a document we were just talking about
with the previous hearing the primary
sponsor for this bill is representative
barry representative barry
welcome to introduce your bill and why
don't you just stay seated right where
you
are matt sharon and fellow committee
members today came before you to
introduce hb 535 which would eliminate
the qualified voter half david
as i've spoke about our election laws
many times before
i still want to go over the record for
the record what it takes for someone to
save they register in the state of new
hampshire and the requirements for
someone to do so
in new hampshire someone may legally
vote here who has been in the state for
30 seconds as new hampshire has no
durational requirements to vote
all they have to do is walk into a
polling location on election day and
register to vote when they register to
vote they currently do not have to
present any photo id or proof of
domicile the way they get around it
having to show a photo id is with a
qualified voter affidavit put it more
simply do not actually know who they are
when they register to vote because they
don't have to produce any proof that
they are who they say they are
this bill will in effect make the voter
showing photo id to in some way prove
as to the issue of requiring an id i
went to talk about my own experience
after graduating college i moved 11
times in five years despite being
employed the whole time and jobs that
often required me to work long hours
i've always managed to have an id
the notion that having an id is a burden
is thin to say the least you need a
photo id to fly on a plane open a bank
account buy alcohol drive a car get
married rent a hotel room and even
purchase cold medicine
to put it bluntly unless you never leave
your house which you would also need an
id to rent or get a mortgage
and never get sick you need a photo id
hp 535 does not offer the type of does
not alter the type of id you would
accept i'm sure some detractors will say
that this bill it will somehow attempt
to affect the college vote but college
students can would still be able to use
their out-of-state photo id to register
they may they may still register on
election day and they would still not
have to provide any proof of domicile
in fact i would
positively increase voter turnout by
restoring faith in our elections to
those who currently have serious doubt
as to about our elections
i will remind the committee that in the
latest saint anthony poll 36
of new hampshire voters did not select a
very confident option as to the absolute
confidence in the integrity of our
election
as i said to put it in layman's terms 36
percent of new hampshire residents are
not very confident in our elections in
fact 17
said they were not at all confident in
the integrity of our elections so nearly
one-fifth of our citizens have zero
faith in our elections
just last week we heard from an
immigrant and newly invented citizen
that she was disheartened to vote in her
first election due to our election laws
that provide zero accountability
the right to vote is sacred but so is
having faith in the outcome of that vote
new hampshire residents deserve to know
who is voting in their elections and
this bill would accomplish that while
not preventing any real barrier to the
ballot box
thank you representative barry for rep
introducing the bill does anybody have
any questions for representative barry
here in the committee room
or attending online
i do
oh see now i'm looking i've got the
raised hand but not the visual
representative lane
thank you uh madam chair representative
berry are can you point to incidences of
fraud uh related to these affidavits
walked in can you can you hear me now
yeah it was very muffled
okay i'm sorry in 2016 a man in lebanon
new hampshire walked in to register to
vote he voted he walked out of the form
location came back two to three hours
later with a blonde wig on and
registered to vote to leave using what i
believe was the qualified voter
affidavit because they did not have an
follow-up please sure
was this reported to the secretary of
state or the ag's office yes i believe
it was prosecuted but only because the
individual for some reason after the
election attempted to attain an id based
on the new identity
so it was a it was a fluke that we found
this morning
[Music]
further questions for representative
barry
and also now i'm trying to find a
follow-up the person did cast two
ballots
so
the crime was committed the vote was
fraud
i'm not seeing any
thank you
we have a few people signed up to speak
on this bill ms nelson are you still
with us if you are could you raise your
hand please
the morning has gone a little longer
than scheduled so i'm sure some people
who thought they might be able to be
here are not able to uh mr barnes are
you still with us
i think i've got you oop don't move on
me
um
mr barnes welcome back to the committee
i believe if you unmute you'll be able
hello again um
rejoining the orchestra
thank you for
taking my testimony i just want to say
very briefly respectful of your time
the bill seems to be premised on some
polls that talk about confidence in our
elections and
i wouldn't
base
state legislation on the results of
polls which are notoriously unreliable
and depend on the questions asked and
people could lack confidence in our
elections
for a hundred different reasons
and
it's not clear that this is the one
that's all i will
reserve my time or
give back my time to the chair thank you
very much thank you very much mr barnes
your perseverance this morning is
appreciated does anybody have any
i'm not seeing any so
thank you also signed up to speak this
morning on this bill is henry
clementowitz i'm assuming on behalf of
the aclu i believe we did receive
written testimony on this bill also
welcome back
mr clementowitz
thank you again
and good afternoon this time members of
the house election law committee again
uh henry clementowicz on behalf of the
ac new hampshire
so this bill i'm i'll be brief because a
lot of this bill
is included in this
raises some of the same issues as hb 531
um as i said before in in that hearing
in fish versus schwab the 10th circuit
from the summer uh struck down on
constitutional grounds a kansas law that
required people to have documentary
proof of citizenship when they were
trying to register to vote much like
uh the provision in this law um
i want to respond briefly to something
that was made by uh the time sponsor a
point that was made which is um there
are much fewer
um
documents that are available to prove
citizenship than there are
photo ids right so when a person
registers to vote they have to prove
citizenship age domicile and identity
and the documents that come to mind that
i can think of that prove citizenship
are limited to birth certificate
passport
um
and naturalization papers and so a
driver's license a new hampshire
driver's license for example does not
prove citizenship because you don't need
to be a citizen to get a new hampshire
driver's license i mean so people with
only a driver's license under this bill
would not be able to register to vote
and to vote and so again i just wanted
to
point out to the committee
in on november 3rd 2020 over 800 people
in new hampshire used the qualified
voter affidavit to prove citizenship
presumably because they didn't have
other proof of citizenship when they
registered to vote and so those 800
something people would be
disenfranchised as would the about 637
who use the affidavit to prove identity
when registered vote and then finally i
i meant to mention this in the last
hearing but i'll mention it now
a right to know request response from
the attorney general's office
tells me that
as of
friday
the attorney general's office out of the
over 1 million votes that were cast in
the september 8th and november 3rd 2020
primaries has opened up investigations
into only 17
uh potential wrongful voting cases and
has brought so far
zero civil or criminal proceedings
in relation to alleged wrongful voting
stemming from those elections so
um
on the one hand
this um law would seek to prevent uh
stop fraud which uh we know is
vanishingly rare and in fact only 17
cases have even been investigated and on
the other hand it would it would prevent
about 1400 people from being able to
register to vote um on election day so
that concludes my testimony and i'm
happy to take
uh questions if there are any
questions from committee members in the
room
representative murray was that a
question or was that a
pen wave okay
just checking
all right thank you very much for
joining us this morning
also requesting to speak on this matter
is mr meyer mr meyer i think if you won
uh hi good morning members of the
committee again madam chairwoman my name
is lucas meyer again for the record i
live in manchester new hampshire
testifying um as a citizen
um here in uh opposition uh to hb
uh 535 again not to belabor the point
brought up by uh uh henry clowitz um
but again a a qualified voter affidavit
form is a legally binding form uh this
bill appears to be
a solution in search of a problem um
legislating based off lies of voter
fraud or very infrequent cases of voter
error should not be
how we want to it
how we change how our elections are
administered um this bill um certainly
uh would target new americans uh who do
not have their naturalization papers
and therefore will not be able to
register to vote um i also think it's
important to remember that if a person
registers to vote on election day
without an id they are already having
their picture taken as an additional
security step and if this committee is
serious about
catching cases of
voter error or
the very
rare instances of voter fraud
they should look towards the electronic
registration information center
which would
catch those cases of voter error weeks
after the election
and i will leave it at that thank you
representative prudhomme o'brien thank
you do those voters that you talk about
if a person registers to vote on
election day without an id as the law
currently stands their picture will be
taken
thank you
further questions for committee members
no
anybody on the plan anybody from the
i'm not seeing any buddy so thank you mr
meyer
is there anybody else in attendance
for the hearing on hb 535 who would like
to speak brian beal joins us from open
democracy
thank you madam chair um i'm brian beal
again from open democracy action
i
rise to speak in opposition of hb 535
i am
i live in alton bay and open democracy
action works on pro-democracy issues
including the protection of our inherent
american freedom to vote
filing and a qualified voter affidavit
does not mean you get a free pass
the attorney general's office follows up
with a letter asking the voter to submit
the required documentation and follows
up
followed up if necessary by an
investigator from the ag's office
if you don't provide this documentation
you can receive a substantial fine if
you provide fraudulent information you
can be penalized with a five thousand
dollar fine not a small factor and it
would seem more prudent and patriotic
uh to leave uh the qualified voter
affidavit intact let our citizens vote
and properly fund the attorney general's
office to do a thorough follow-up uh
with these voters removing the provision
for qualified voter affidavits plainly
makes voting more difficult and during
the 2020 general election open democracy
fielded 90 poll observers around the
state reports from our observers
indicated that huge numbers of
people from both parties registered same
day as attorney clementowitz noted the
number of people using the uh qualified
voter affidavits was very small weighing
the number of people who in both parties
who use this method and
the few that need the affidavit it would
seem that this bill would hurt more
voters than it would add to election
integrity so i respectfully ask that you
vote hb 535 in expedia to legislate and
i thank you again for the opportunity to
speak madam chair and members of the
committee
thank you for joining us
anybody have any questions for mr
biel
here or online
um
okay thank you very much mr beale
um i don't have anybody else with their
hand raised at this time and i've got
yeah
and i've gone through everybody signed
up but deputy scanlon has
joined us
and has indicated that he would like to
say something deputy scanlon
and thank you madam chair for the record
i'm david scanlon deputy secretary of
state and i just wanted to address a
question that was posed to
representative perdom o'brien a about
when a
photo was taken
currently there are no photos taken of
voters registering to vote using an
affidavit although there is a bill
currently pending before your committee
that would
provide for that the only time that a
photo is taken in the polling place
when a voter signs an affidavit is when
there is a voter that is
that does not have an acceptable form of
id
and to meet the requirement they have to
fill out a challenge photo david and
have their photo taken
but that does not happen at the voter
registration table
thank you question deputy scanlan
because that's what we're talking about
voters who are already registered and
forget to bring their id to the poll is
that correct that's correct
thank you
any further questions from members of
or
online
i'm not seeing anybody is there anybody
else
i'm not seeing anybody so
um thank you everybody for participating
in your attentiveness we are now going
to start
i'm going to close that public hearing
and we will start the public hearing on
hb 538 relative to domicile residency
voter registration and investigation of
voter verification letters in relative
to the terms resident inhabitant
residents and
residency the prime sponsor on this bill
is representative horgan who joins us
so representative horgan you are unmuted
representative horrigan i think you're
somewhere in the land of panelists there
you are go go ahead oh thank you so i
represent timothy horrigan i still
represent stratford county district six
the towns of durham and madbury and
durham is not this is not coincidentally
a college town is
i don't need to remind you it's hp 538
is a combination of two bills which i
sponsored uh with many co-sponsors in
2019 they
passed both houses and then were vetoed
by the governor which um well i think
that was a mistake in his part
and um
one of these bills hp 106 also covered
the same ground as hb67 which
suffered the same
same fate it was also passed by both
houses and veto but that was then this
is now i actually
brought those two backs in 2020 but
nothing you know they
got to the house and then they kind of
got lost in the
got lost when the pandemic struck us um
so they were but we're back um i decided
to combine them two bills into one
hb 106 which is also hb 1279 the next
year is at the end of the very long bill
before the committee today it
section 16 out of 18. makes
the rest of it hp 105 which is also hp
1653 i says here makes up the first 15
sections actually it was one for 15 and
then also uh
17 one before the enabling clause
is a provision allowing
what they call havo funds to be used by
the secretary of state's office to pay
for some of the things that the bill
uh voter registration so the
purpose of this is undo three uh earlier
bills
which unfairly restrict voting rights
generally make the voting process less
user friendly or to put away more user
hostile and just generally more
complicated so those three
built very bad builds for hb 1264 which
passed in 2018 sb3 which passed in 2017
and then also there was sb 318 which
passed in 2012 and um
one comma roman numeral one which we
were discussing earlier um
that's also affected by this but we're
adding a line to the end of it
which says a person's claim of domicile
for voting purposes and not being
conclusive for the person's residence
for any other legal purpose which is
mostly trying to uh
undo some of the confusion about things
like driver's licenses and vehicle
registration a bunch of other things
which
don't have anything really to do with
the right to vote you know you don't
have to own a car or
you never driver's licenses etc but
which always get mixed up in that issue
so that's uh
just um these bad laws that we passed
between 2012 and 2018 don't just affect
students but um my constituents in
durham which is a college town
justifiably perceived these changes as
an attack on students right to vote so
every citizen over the age of 18 has the
right to vote anywhere he or she lives
um regardless of why he or she moved
there and regardless of how long ago and
generally speaking
it's not the people in the college towns
who are so worried about students voting
it's usually people from towns that have
you know don't have colleges so we're
usually
i found this in in other college
communities they're usually pretty
welcoming of uh students who want to get
involved and want to vote so activists
you know the active
you know the non-student activities is
usually glad to have the students um
voting and doing other things it's um so
it's usually the problem is usually
outside these towns so that's uh
just protects the right to vote i think
i think um
i think the uh i think we should give
the governor a chance to correct the
mistake he made back in 2019 and um so i
heard uh obviously they'll take a
bipartisan effort but uh i urge the
community here's the committee to
pass hp 538 and it basically just
just simplifies
this makes the whole issue a little less
complicated right now i think the law is
pretty
pretty convoluted and it will be kind of
convoluted yep this passes but it will
be a little bit simpler and fairer and
just
more workable for everyone else so
that's uh
that's basically what i have to say
about my bill and i guess i know we're
already uh
about exactly an hour behind schedule
which actually is not as bad as i feared
but trying to be happy to take any
questions if anybody wants a
wants to ask them
thank you representative horrigan for
introducing the bill and being willing
to take questions is there anybody
um who would like to ask any questions
committee members any questions of
i'm not seeing any so thank you
representative horgan
for representing the bill also signed up
to speak on this bill
is deborah nelson deborah nelson if
mr barnes are you still with us mr
barnes i have you registered to speak on
thank you mr barnes
if you unmute i think you should be all
i am still here and i thank you again
for giving me the opportunity to speak
um
i will save you the time and let you go
along hopefully we'll catch up with our
time thank you madam chair
thank you very much mr barnes
um and i would understand you to be
opposed to the bill right
or in favor of the bill just to clarify
because you didn't say that as you
signed right yes yes
if you because it's helpful if you've
spoken at least thank you for saving the
time but i appreciate you saying your
position on the bill okay thank you
madam chair
thank you also um
joining us this morning to speak on this
bill is representative
abramson representative abramson i
believe you should be able to join us
if you unmute
yep i unmuted and then it muted me again
um i've
representative lynn and i have been
going back and forth with the municipal
county for another bill we tried to
introduce house bill 531 i wonder if it
would be out of order to bring it up or
introduce it now
i have no idea what you're talking about
representative abramson um house bill
531 was scheduled for 10 30 a.m relative
to determining qualifications of voters
and establishing provisional voter
and there was a reference for an
amendment and i texted our
pam smarling
our very able legislative assistant who
knew nothing about an amendment so she
wasn't able to send us it down
to us
i have officially closed the public
hearing um
representative abramson and i don't know
that i want to establish the precedent
so if you have an
amendment if you could send that along
to the committee
with
written testimony
we would be happy to consider it an
executive session
okay i did send an amendment to the
election law committee a couple of weeks
ago so i'll i'll go find that and i'll
resubmit that
is that the same amendment that we're
talking about
it it may very well be i'm not sure if
i'm the sponsor on that one there may be
another amendment that's come through
we've been getting a number of
amendments sent so if you could get that
clarified and send it as a new
um submission to us that would be
terrific
okay and if the chair would be willing
to
um establish a subcommittee i could come
in and speak for that if you want to get
into the nuts and bolts of this
but that's obviously up to the committee
okay so far we haven't done any
subcommittees and we'll have to see how
the committee feels about doing that as
we exec our last bills
all right thank you thank you very much
thank you representative abramson is
there anybody else here to speak in
regards to 538
538 is proposed by representative horgan
relative to certain
requirements and definitions for voting
i'm not seeing any so i'm going to close
the public hearing on 5 38.
5 38 was the last bill that we had
scheduled for public hearing this
morning
we have executive sessions scheduled
today
um executive session was scheduled to
begin possibly at 12 depending where we
were
with a break perhaps for lunch
i'm going to consolidate the bills that
are on for executive session and begin
with them at 1
30. so
we are on break until 1 30.
thank you everybody for staying with us
all morning and we'll see you again
in
so
all right this is barbara griffin
speaking this is the new hampshire house
election committee
i want to thank everybody on the
committee for their perseverance with my
bad scheduling and the conduct of the
hearings this morning
this afternoon we have some
bills scheduled for
executive session i'm just going to run
through them again
61 144 285 291
292 327 406 537
372 480 491
516 and
um
so
having said that i think
we are
all here do you have the rules with
representative murray
set for representative ward right yes
okay and
i just i i apologize to the committee i
have a very weird screen in front of me
um
they haven't quite figured out how to
keep
the panelists the only ones on the
screen so i we end up with a lot more
more people than are on the committee
um we are going to go into executive
session
i will just remind people that if you
were voting and not on the screen i need
you to be on the screen
to vote
um so
with that
uh the first bill
for today is house bill
61.
is relative to absentee voting and
allowing for the partial
processing of absentee ballots prior
to election day we had a public hearing
on that last week
on the fourth
is their emotion on hb61
representative will seconds it
would you like to speak to your motion
i would madam chair uh some weeks ago i
traveled to a distant state to transact
business
it served for my personal protection and
for the protection of an
orderly society to verify my
identity to enter a bus to board an
airplane to purchase a property even to
withdraw my own money from my own bank
account
some would argue that the high privilege
of voting an act that directs the
destiny of the state and country love
should be done casually and with little
or no assurance that the person voting
is precisely who he or she says she is
this bill proposes to expand absentee
voting without establishing clear
verifiable and irrefutable evidence that
the person so directing the destiny of
our towns cities state and nation are
precisely who they say they are
madam chair and fellow committee members
imagine if banks allowed absentee
withdrawal of your money from your
account at your bank without clear proof
of identification just a flippant
concept of we trust people to do the
right thing that's a scary thought isn't
it
i urge you to vote itl on this proposal
to expand absentee voting without
establishing a process for clear
absolute and verifiable identification
would anybody else like to speak to the
motion on the floor the motion on the
i'm not seeing anything so i'm going to
[Music]
yes
all right let's call him at the end of
the rule to see if he gets on continue
representative ward
no representative murray
no
sorry
representative paper
no
we can't hear you again but is that a no
vote
no
yep
hb 61 was inexpedient to legislate the
vote was 11 to 1.
i will wait to hear on a minority report
from
representative cody
eleven to eight excuse me eleven to
eight
i wrote it down right
uh the next bill to be
considered by this
committee an executive session is hb
this had a public hearing
on march 4th it modifies the absentee
ballot request form
is there a motion on this bill
representative quayley yes thank you
madden chairman i move that the
committee fined hb 144 in expedient to
legislate
is there a second i second that
representative hayward seconds it would
you like to speak to your motion
representative queeley yes it would
matter chairman thank you
this bill proposes changes to the
application forms for absentee ballots
by amending rsa 657
4 and changes to the absentee ballot
affidavit envelopes
i'm ending rsa 657 7.
i believe that some of the proposed
changes are in conflict
with the absentee voting eligibility
requirements of rsa 657 1.
for example application change is
proposed in section 1 of hb 144 and this
is on page 1 line 30 page two lines two
to six
appear to conflict with the stipulation
of rsa 657
colon one
section roman numeral two that
eligibility is due to national weather
service winter storm warnings etc for
election day apply only to absentee
voting on the monday before election day
and that an applicant must satisfy other
conditions listed in rsa 657
colon 1 roman numeral 2 parts a and b
therefore it is my opinion that the
committee should find hb 144 inexpedient
is there any further discussion on hb
from anybody here or online
representative murray
yeah may i just have a point of order
for one second i think that um
representative cody is trying to get in
could somebody
i can resend him the link madam chairman
i don't um
i don't know i can i also try to find
tech support do you know what the nature
of the problem is
i don't
yeah why don't you resend the link i
think sometimes if you start from a new
email with a new link sometimes it works
different
all right i'll do that in
all right we'll wait representative
murray to your point i actually hadn't
looked at my screen i didn't realize he
wasn't on yet let's wait a couple of
minutes to see if he can get on
so we're in
let me i just ask everybody while we
while we're on hold to see if
representative cody can get on could
everybody hear the clerk read the names
because we've got a different microphone
set up there he is representative cody
joins us could you hear her calling the
names all right
no
[Music]
thank you
thank you madam chair i i for some
reason i was de-panelisted for some
reason
i have nothing to do with it i just want
you to know
i'm sure not madam chair i wouldn't have
a clue i'm just figuring out how to
raise and lower hands never mind do
anything that fast and and the message
that you have on your phone that says
i've been deep panelistic is for me in
case you don't recognize the phone
number
all right
um
so
so the clerk if i don't do it people
remind me the clerk is going to have to
depress the red button on her microphone
when she does the rules so you can hear
her
all right
um
representative cody now joins us we are
on house bill 144
the motion on the floor is itl
um i asked if anybody wanted to say
anything
and i am not seeing any comments so i'm
going to ask the clerk to call the roll
is your red button pressed
there you go okay representative
mcdonald
yeah
representative fruit home o'brien
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes representative
trojan yes representative barry yes
representative groan
representative quailey yes clerks yes
representative cody motion is itl is
that right
yes
uh the end the vote is no
could we just see you for second
representative cody
certainly one moment
thank you
representative murray
no
representative bergeron no
representative sandler
no
representative hamer now
representative lane
no
representative freitas
madam chair
yes
okay so 11 to 9.
okay
thank you hb 144
will be reported and expedient to
legislate i will wait to hear on a
um
hb 285 is also before us this morning
this is relative to the verification of
voting
checklists
we had a public hearing on this bill
on february
12th
is there a motion on hb 285
representative prudhomme o'brien
thank you i i move out to pass on uh 285
is there a second second
would you like to speak to your motion
yes this bill cleans up our uh
checklists and it provides for more
oversight for
uh the secretary of state and the uh to
to uh
follow up and
alert town clerks
when
similar names are found registered in
more than one community
and also has provisions that would
have the allow the
division of motor vehicles to do the
same sort of thing when there is a
change of address this is a good idea
and this will help to clarify the
expectations for all communities and uh
standardize that and improve that that
situation here in our state so i'm yeah
i think it's a good deal and uh not to
pass
thank you are there any other comments
on
hb 285 which is before this committee
with the motion
of ought to pass
i'm not seeing any
comments or
anybody wanting to make a comment so i'm
going to ask the clerk to call for the
role
representative mcdonald
yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative trojan
representative berry
representative groan yes
representative quailey yes
clerk is yes
representative cody
no
murray
represent representative bergeron no
representative sandler
no
representative hamer
representative lane
now
representative freitas
no
representative hamlet
and representing your head
no
madam chair
yes
hb
285 will go to the full house with the
committee recommendation vote 11 of
ought to pass i will wait to hear
291 is the next bill notice for action
this afternoon 291 had a public hearing
on three
this is related to the public inspection
of ballot absentee less
um
does anybody have a motion on hb 291
representative sweeney madam chair i
move ought to pass
is there a second second emotion
representative sweeney would you like to
speak to your motion thank you madam
chair we have heard in our committee not
only in the testimony on this bill but
on a number of other bills
regarding the public's trust in our
elections this bill would move forward
and seeks to expand public trust in our
elections and at this time we should be
supportive of such moves so that's why i
would encourage the committee to vote
for
thank you
is there anybody else who wishes to
i'm seeing nana in the rumor online i'm
going to ask the clerk to call the role
the vote before the committee is
ought to pass hb 291
representative mcdonald yes
representative fruit home o'brien
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative trojan yes representative
barry yes representative groan yes
representative quayley yes
clerk is yes
representative cody no
thank you
representative murray you're welcome
no
representative bergeron no
representative sandler
no
representative hamer
representative lane
no
representative freitas
representative hamlet
no
representative your head
madam chair yes
house bill 291 will be reported to the
full houses ought to pass and i'll wait
to hear on a minority report
the next bill before the committee this
afternoon is house bill 292
relative to the absentee ballot
application process
this had a presentation before
the committee on the fourth which uh of
march
is their emotion on hb 92 representative
groin do you have a motion
madam chair i move hb 292 ought to
it's
representative growing would you like to
speak to your motion
yes i would uh this bill is one small
but important step in verifying the
identity of a voter who requests that a
ballot be sent to an address other than
the address shown on the voter checklist
voting is a high privilege an act that
directs the destiny of the state and
country we love to be done with clear
and verifiable evidence that the person
voting is precisely who he or she says
she he or she is this bill moves us
toward that reasonable goal i urge you
to vote pass on hb 292.
thank you representative growin
is there anybody else who wishes to
speak
to the
motion on the floor
i'm looking in person and on the screen
i'm not seeing anybody so i'm going to
ask the clerk to call the role
the bill is hb 292 and the motion on the
floor is otp
about to pass
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative trojan yes representative
barry yes
representative brown yes
representative quayley yes
yes representative cody
no
representative murray thank you
no representative bergeron no
representative sandler
no
representative hamer
representative lane
no
representative freitas
representative hamlet
no
you represented muirhead no
madam cheer
yes
hb 292 will go on the calendar as
ought to pass i will wait to hear on a
minority report the next uh bill
scheduled
uh for today or at least that was on our
list
was 3 27 there was a public hearing on
there is the response we're going to
continue that to wednesday
there was some question about whether or
not someone wanted to do an amendment so
we're continuing that till wednesday
um
some people think doing this stuff
online is easier i'm not always quite
sure that it's worked out that way so
uh 327 please put on your list for
wednesday
the next
um
bill
is hb 406 this had a public hearing on
3-4 this was relative to the ability of
the public to observe the processing and
counting
of absentee ballots
um is there a motion on this matter
representative prudhomme o'brien
yes i move to retain the bill it's not
quite ready for prime time is there a
second
a second the motion madam chair thank
we have time to work on this bill it's
related to some other bills that are
similar in nature that we will be taking
up soon and
we'll get to this when that's more
appropriate
there any further discussion on the
motion on the floor which is to retain
hbo b 406. i'm yes ma'am check could i
just ask what's contemplated
to be
representative prudhommer bryant i'm
sorry we're on 406. is this right i'm
getting yeah
okay i'm getting some different feedback
here uh
we're not
we're i think there's still some things
to discuss about this because there are
other bills that are related to the
processing and counting of absentee
ballots that we
that may
that are related to this one and should
those pass this may not be relevant so
we
i i'm not sure my recollection that i'll
be voting for retaining is because
there's some question as to whether we
need to further define the
pre-processing procedure and i think
that
um
the public hearing testimony on this
indicated that the issue that drove the
bill was actually a pre-processing issue
not
an election day issue so i think in
light of the need of amendments and
other bills the sponsor thought that
retaining it was
more appropriate and i apologize for
putting words in the sponsor's mouth but
i'm just sort of more geared up on where
we are then it's hard to keep up i know
with 21 bills just today alone it's it
is it is a challenge
so i hope representative cody that gives
you a little more insight
a little more yes madam chair thank you
there any other questions or discussion
i'm not seeing any so i'm going to ask
the clerk to call the role
representative
representative mcdonald yes
representative food home o'brien
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative trojan yes
representative barry
yes representative crone yes
representative quailey yes clerk says
yes
representative cody
no with all due respect to the chair
and can we see you representative cody
you could see me yes in one moment thank
you
representative murray
no
representative bergeron no
representative sandler
no
representative hamer
representative lane
no
representative freitas
representative hamlet
yes
representative your head
no
madam chair
yes
okay so that's 12 to 8.
hb 406 will be reported to the clerk's
office as retained
the next bill to be considered by this
committee is 537
this is relative to the date of the
state primary the public hearing on this
was january 29th which seems a lot
longer away than a little over a month
um and this change of the state primary
was represented as being at the request
of the secretary of state in regards to
uh special circumstances processing
yokaba ballots
is
there a motion on this representative
wells
their motion on the floor is to retain
house bill 537 representative wells
would you like to speak to your motion
on your bill
thank you madam chair as the secretary
of state stated
every so many years there's not enough
time to mail out the
okava ballots
and since this has been
a new hampshire primary practice since
and we are considering other time frames
and by time frames you're referring to
time frame other dates to possibly move
the primary yes okay
is there any further discussion on the
motion on the floor which is to retain
hb537
i'm not seeing anything so i'm going to
ask the clerk to call the role
representative mcdonald
yes
representative prudhomme o'brien
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative trojan yes
representative barry yes representative
groan yes
representative kweily
yes
clerk is yes representative cody yes
representative murray
yes
representative bergeron yes
representative sandler
yes
representative hamer
representative lane
yes
representative freitas
representative hamlet
yes
representative muirhead yes
madam chair
yes okay it's 20 to zero hb 537 is
retained by the committee the vote was
to zero to zero
um our next block of bills to be
voted on today was
372 480 491 516
and 5
24.
um hb
had a public hearing on march 4th
and this was relative to the enforcement
of election laws
there was
also an amendment
sent out to the committee i believe zero
six four one h
does anybody have a motion to make on
372 or the amendment representative
sweeney yeah thank you madam chair i
move we find house bill 372 and
expedient to legislate and i'd like to
speak to my motion is there
a
representative mcdonald's second it go
ahead
uh while i uh appreciate the sponsor's
intent of of the of the bill
there were significant opposition from
the county attorneys and their their
representative uh to including them in
the process for enforcing election laws
and i believe that we as a state should
be focused on one entity enforcing our
laws um and if this committee so chooses
at a future date with future legislation
uh focuses on that entity and not
expanding the burden to other entities
throughout the state that aren't
currently prepared for this
so i do agree with the intention of the
bill
i understand where the sponsor was
coming from but i do not believe that
the way that he
uh prescribed it is the way we should go
forward thank you
are there any other questions or
comments on the motion
on the floor which is inexpedient to
i'm not seeing any so i'm going to ask
the clerk to call the rule
representative mcdonald yes
representative frutom o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative trojan
yes
representative barry yes
representative crone yes
representative quality yes
clerk is yes representative cody
yes
representative murray
representative bergeron yes
representative sandler
yes
hamer
representative lane
yes
representative freitas
representative hamlet
yes
representing your head
madam chair
yes
20 to 0.
hb 372 will go to the house as
recommended to be found inexpedient to
legislate with if there is no objection
i will be recommending this go on the
consent calendar
the next bill
this committee has before to consider is
hb 480 relative to the verification
of ballots cast in an election
um this was had a public hearing on
three
five is there a motion on hb 480
representative barry i guess madam
chairman i moved that uh we retained a
hospital before
is there a second
oh second though representative sweeney
it seconds it
representative barry would you like to
speak to your motion very briefly man
chairman the sponsor of this bill
contacting me he's still in the process
working with the secretary of state
on this bill so ask that if he retains
so
i'm honoring his wishes
is there any further
discussion on hb 480 which is now before
i'm not seeing any
hands online in person or in pictures so
if the clerk could call the role
representative mcdonald
yes
representative
hear her
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative trojan yes
representative barry
yes
representative groan yes
representative quayley yes
clerk is yes
representative cody
let's give him a minute i'm sorry
if we can see you
oh certainly
thank you
representative murray
no
representative bergeron no
representative sandler
no
representative hamer
representative lane
no
representative freitas no
representative hamlet
no
representative
madam chair
yes
it's 11 to 9.
hb 480 will be
retained
the next bill scheduled to be addressed
this afternoon
is 491 relative to over voted ballots we
had a public hearing on this
on march
5th
is there a motion
of representative terosian
yes madam chair i make a motion to find
house bill 491 any speeding to legislate
is there a second
i second that representative prudhomme
o'brien's second cities would you like
to speak to your motion yes thank you
madam chair
so we've heard all day today how
important our voting rights are
in this state and it's one of the most
sacred rights that we have and most
important things that we do today
so in light of that i believe that we
pay attention to
the ballot
and we've heard some
some discussion on this bill that
sometimes people
make a mistake
well that's possible in life and
certainly happens and and even people
that are informed sometimes
make a mark in the wrong place at some
point you have to draw the line as to
to to how
long you can go with with you know
opening things back up and and giving
somebody a chance to take another look
at it i mean you could one could i you
could you could drag the process on
forever
so in light of that there are ways you
can
to minimize
the error
most towns virtually every town i'm
aware of in the state
um
puts a sample ballot on to their website
and most towns allow you to go into the
town clerk and pick up a sample ballot
and if you examine the ballots in fact
in our time we have an election tomorrow
town election you can take a look at the
ballot you can see who's on the ballot
you can research who's on it warn
take a look if it's a race that has more
than one person running and you can vote
more than one you can see those numbers
so in light of all of that i believe um
we shouldn't change this because again
if we do it also potentially creates a
couple different classes because under
the analysis of this bill it requires
ballots that include a federal office
but not necessarily ones that don't so
on one hand you're going to allow
another hand you're not and then if
somebody chooses to
to
change it they may one could argue that
maybe over franchise where somebody else
that doesn't or doesn't have a chance to
would be under franchise so in light of
all of these reasons i i ask you to join
me in finding this legislation in
exceeding the legislate thank you does
anybody else wish to speak to the motion
on the floor representative prudhomme
o'brien thank you i i heard somebody
make a comment first of all this is not
exactly related but that they could not
hear me when i was voting and i was uh
not using my microphone i think
people know i voted in the with the
majority of all the bills that we've
heard so far so i just want to let that
be said
uh this bill
i think has some positive intentions
and
that's what the sponsor was going for
but i don't think
it's appropriate
for the towns that have hand counts they
don't put the ballots into the ballot
counting machine
and that means that in order to find out
if someone is doing an overvote you have
to look at their ballot when they're in
front of you
giving you their ballot so these are
some major privacy issues for those
people and that's why this bill should
not that should be an expedient to
legislate it should not pass
is there any further discussion on hb
491 which is in front of the committee
with the motion of inexpedient to
legislate
i'm not seeing anything
we're hearing so i'm going to ask the
clerk to come madame clark
i'm sorry
there are several there were several of
us raising our hands i think oh okay i'm
sorry i'm
i think maybe even with these glasses i
need to be closer to the screen
representative lane
uh i want to speak in opposition to the
motion please okay go ahead
um this bill uh does not
is aimed at getting
correcting machine mistakes not
necessarily voter mistakes as
representative porter testified many of
these that are rejected by the machine
are because of errors or marks on the
ballots themselves it's not due to
mistakes and given the importance of
being of a of an election and our right
to vote i think it's important that we
give somebody an extra few minutes if
they need it to either figure out if
it's the machine or if they didn't color
in the block the right color and it does
not affect the hand votes towns
it only applies to the machine
vote towns does not i do not think it
creates a class a special class
i will be voting against
thank you representative lane does
somebody else have their hand up i'm not
seeing an electronic hand but if there
thank you i don't i don't think i'm
seeing anything else i i will just say
that my recollection was the concern was
not that this was machine count but that
people voting in hand count towns would
not have the same opportunity to have
their ballot corrected because those
ballots go directly into a box that are
not removed to the end of the night
um so there were a couple of different
distinctions as to what was going on
i'm not seeing any so i'm going to ask
the clerk to call a roll which is hb
hb516
excuse me 491
ocean on the floor is it
l
all right i've got the word go thank you
natalie representative wells
representative mcdonald yes
representative fruit home o'brien
yes
representative sweeney yes
leonard hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative
yes representative barry yes
representative crone yes
representative quayley yes
clerk is yes representative cody
no
thank you
representative murray of p1 mu will be
all set oh i'm sorry i i thought i was
unmuted i no
thanks
representative bergeron no
representative sandler no
representative hamer
no
representative lane
freitas
no
representative hamlet
representative your head
no
madam chair
yes
okay 11-9
491 will be recommended to the house as
inexpedient to legislate i'll wait to
hear on a
minority report
the next bill before us today is 5 16
allowing voters to vote by absentee
ballot
with no excuse
the public hearing on this was
march
4th
is there someone who wants to make a
motion on this representative mooney
madam chairman i would make a motion
that we itl house bill 516.
is there a second
madam chair i make a motion uh i make
the second to uh i tell
thank you representative teresa and
representative mooney would you like to
speak to your motion i would thank you
so much
this bill takes out excuse
from excused voting that is absentee
voting historically absentee voting is
allowed when there is an excuse for one
reason or another to not appear in
person on election day
to adopt this bill would be to truly
substantially change our elections in
our election day and there really was no
sustaining evidence that needs to be
done
so for that reason i would ask my
colleagues to support a motion of itl
on house bill 5 16.
thank you representative mooney is there
anybody else that would like to speak to
the motion
that's on the floor
yes i would madam chair i'd like to
speak against the motion
thank you representative cody
and all i would like to say is of course
as we saw in november
essentially that's the
situation we we were operating under
in the sense that
as covid was allowed as an excuse for
not voting
uh
operationally we had that situation and
i thought things went rather well and
i've always thought it was rather
ridiculous because we we have an
expansive list of exceptions
to that particular statute and i think
that we ought to be honest and just say
you know if you want to vote absentee
you ought to be able to thank you
thank you representative cody for
commenting on it
is there any further discussion on it
the motion on the floor is to
without any other comments i'll ask the
clerk to call the roll
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes
representative
yes representative barry yes
representative crone yes
representative quayley yes
clerk is yes
representative cody
no
representative murray no
representative bergeron no
no
representative hamer
thank
you representative lane
no
representative freitas
representative gambling
no
representative your head
madam chia
yes
okay 11 to 9.
hb 516 will go to the floor recommended
inexpedient to legislate i'll wait to
hear on whether they're being minority
report
the next bill on the list for today is
hb 524 we had a public hearing on that
last week on the fifth
and this is regarding requiring the
secretary of state to conduct random
verification counts to polling place
results
um is there a motion on this
is there a second
madam chair i second the motion to
retain
representative groan would you like to
speak to your motion yes i would madam
chair
hb 524 fn proposes to establish a
defined and routine
audit process to verify the accuracy and
integrity of the election process in new
hampshire
this legislature routinely affirms the
importance of routine
audits to assure the integrity and
reliability of our banking and security
industries
those audits only deal with our money
here we are dealing with something even
more important than our money the
integrity of our vote i do believe this
very important matter needs to be
addressed but i believe this bill needs
some additional work to clarify and
expand its scope so i ask you to vote to
retain h.b 524.
thank you representative growings as
um i representative bergeron would you
yes madam chairman if i may
um
i'm going to
vote against the motion to retain
and my reason for doing so is that
this is not an
burdensome or unreasonable bill that
would establish an audit process
the bill can easily be implemented uh i
also think it's it's time that we
stopped kicking the audit can down the
road
last session we had several bills before
the committee
um asking that some kind of
post-election audit be established
and one of those bills senate bill 283
which was sponsored by senator gray
required that the secretary of state
submit a report by november 1st on
conducting audits of electronic ballot
accounting devices
as well as
conducting uh
post-election audits
and
that report was supposed to be submitted
by november 1st
the
draft has not been submitted
unfortunately i think i had written
several reports citing the need and the
expectation that this report would be
coming out as a reason
not to
approve the other bills asking for
post-election audits
i think particularly given what's been
going on in windham
it's time to move forward i know that
senator gray has another bill coming
forward that now wants to establish a
committee to study election audit
counting devices and
let's just stop postponing this this is
a reasonable bill it's easy to implement
does anybody else want to speak to this
motion
representative terezian
thank you madam chair
um i i think most of us agree that we do
want to see this passed and that's why
we're retaining it so we can make sure
we iron out the details so when we pass
it it uh
we've got it correct
that's the reason for the retained
motion
the chair is going to take the
opportunity to say she
she would like to see something pass but
in doing that i am concerned that the
focus is solely on an audit to date we
do not have not had a specific audit
process because we have more recounts
than any other jurisdiction getting a
recount in new hampshire is incredibly
easy
and true a recount deals with a
particular race as compared to
uh the
functioning of the machine across the
ballot
but i think there needs to be an
overview approach to this i am aware
that there are bills coming from the
senate to do something similar
but i am also concerned when i have
someone come in and say that they've
picked
uh three polling places of a particular
place and two polling places randomly
and i guess i would like to know
statistically from an audit standpoint
if there are 240 polling places is that
amount of audits statistically
significant
and i suggest to you that neither the
sponsor or anybody in this room could
answer that question so there's no point
in doing the audit but from that
standpoint in my mind because if all
we're doing is
a check of tabulation we're effectively
doing that with recounts
but i think the concept is incredibly
important and i would like to make sure
that we are not as stopped as a body
this year from addressing it next year
um so i'm going to support the motion to
retain but
i don't like kicking things down the
road
retaining i think other committees are
retaining a lot more bills than we are
because they're sort of doing that and i
and i don't really want to but that's
sort of where i am on this one anybody
else
representative lane
i would agree with attorney i'm sorry
representative bergeron
and uh
mostly because as he referenced we voted
on this i think twice i've only this one
my second term but i think i've seen
this bill two or three times
and
the secretary of state could easily imp
you know put in uh regulations could get
some people to do that i don't think we
have to lay out
all the details in the statute
but
that's all
okay thank you thank you
all right i'm going to ask the clerk to
call the roll
representative mcdonald
yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes representative
trojan yes
representative barry yes
representative groan yes
representative whaley yes
clerk is yes representative cody
no
thank you
hurry
hurry representative murray i'm sorry i
was doing good up until now that's all
right representative murray votes no
thank you
representative bergeron no
representative sandler where'd you go
you're not on my screen
she's muted you did she's here on mute
there we go okay sorry about that i'm
muted and then unmuted uh
no the vote is no
thank you
representative hamer
no
representative lane
representative freitas
no
representative hamlet
representative your head no
madame cheer
yes
okay sir 12
11 to 9.
hb 524 will be retained not the end of
all right
i believe that
concludes what i announced at the
beginning we'd be addressing today
there had been some hope that we were
going to get through all of our business
today but i think given
the issues we're ending this session
with
that turned out to be a little
unrealistic
so um we will be meeting on wednesday at
10 o'clock
at 10 not 9 30
and for those of you present or coming
to lob
it will be back in our lowly 306
308 room i think on the third floor for
those of you observing online we are in
the finance committee room today and
this is like being elevated to really
important people when you sit in this
room at the table so
we will be back in the other section of
lob so to review the bills that we will
be going through on wednesday
will be 40 sb
sb2
we have previously
um
is it 327
327 has been continued
and 98
is
going to be exact on wednesday you
should have received an email
with an amendment for 98
and to tell you the truth somebody
refreshed my recollection is 327 getting
an amendment or did we just continue it
i think it might be getting i'm working
on an amendment right now all right
thank you
all right so what's this status of bills
before the committee
um does anybody have any other business
to bring in front of the committee today
all right see you all on wednesday where
i'm hoping we get through and address
some pretty important issues and get to
a consensus on it so have a good evening
everybody